earlier today
a man drove through the barricades in
the capitol
he killed a cop he got shot hit a knife
and
you know this all this is still
relatively breaking news they're saying
they believe it's not terror-related
though many journalists are expressing
skepticism
not that it is or isn't but that isn't
it a bit too soon
and now we're getting information on the
suspect apparently a black nationalist
and that is
from the new york times it's not just my
opinion they said
that this man was a proponent of the
nation of islam a follower of farrakhan
a
vocal supporter and they mentioned this
is a black nationalist movement
apparently he had posted something on
instagram or facebook that indicated he
was very much a
a leftist identitarian and i'm not
surprised this kind of thing is
happening
but i'm i'm still i'm a bit unsurprised
that they're going to try and downplay
the politics on this one because
things have already been a bit chaotic
in terms of left right culture war
and the establishment seems to be very
much
deferential to and protective of leftist
extremism as we've seen
so we're gonna talk about all this and
it's very heavy stuff we do have a bunch
of other stories things are getting
crazy in crimea i mean this is just it's
heck of a friday right guys joining us
today is
author commentator founder of liberty
junkies julie borowski
hello do you want to just give a really
short quick introduction
hi my name is julie browski i'm a
commentator and author and owner of
libertyjunkies.com
i'm also on youtube julie barrowski cool
right on and
we got yes thank you tim ian crossland
over here
hi everyone oh yeah and you have me in
the corner pushing buttons as always
sour patch lids lydia technically
you know normally we we open and it
tends to be more
humorous and jokey and we let it dry
draw drought a little bit but
uh you know coming up here we always go
through the day trying to figure out
what we're going to talk about
and what the stories are what's
interesting and then you get something
like what happens today
and it's it's scary stuff i mean in any
circumstance if somebody crashed a car
and
and you know got into it with cops we
probably wouldn't talk about that kind
of thing but this is hyper political
in a hyper-polarized space and
there's just so much to go through
there's the establishment democrat
leftist type saying
clearly this was a white male it's
exactly why mitch mcconnell was wrong
they should have doubled down security
and you've got all these demands for
more security so it's just going to get
rough
before we get started i want you to
consider one very important thing
first go to timcast.com become a member
and
youtube absolutely frowns upon these
kinds of conversations
it is this kind of conversation that got
me axed on facebook no joke
when everything went down on january 6th
i did a video just basically saying
here's what's happening and they
told me you're out and you're you're not
allowed back in and i i
okay i guess but if i'm going to report
this i'm going to report the news i
didn't i didn't
say anything against the rules they just
don't want that kind of conversation so
it's very likely youtube does not
appreciate this either this is reality
when news happens news gets reported but
youtube wants to be the
family friendly you know basketball
dunking minecraft
website i'm sorry this is not reality
and so long as we're able to we'll talk
about this stuff so go to timcast.com
become a member and you'll get access to
exclusive members only segments from the
show
last night we did basically a full bonus
episode with michael malus he wanted to
talk about
success you know where we're going and
advice and it was a really interesting
philosophical conversation probably gave
a bunch of
very very important advice you know both
from michael
i think everybody had uh something to
add if you want to learn the
secrets to success and hear our
philosophies our ethos
become a member check out that segment
and don't forget to like share subscribe
hit that notification bell all right
we're getting serious now
this is the story from the new york
times suspect in capital attack
appears to have been a follower of louis
farrakhan for those
familiar he is the leader of the nation
of islam who has repeatedly promoted
anti-semitism
the suspect noah r green 25 was
identified by two law enforcement
officials
and a congressional official he was from
indiana and died of being shot by
capitol police
on facebook mr green had had posted
speeches and articles written by mr
farrakhan
and elijah muhammad who led the nation
of islam from 1934 to 1975
that discussed the decline of america
two law enforcement officials confirmed
that the facebook page which was taken
down on friday had belonged to
mr green mr green posted on facebook
about his personal struggles
especially during the pandemic quote to
be honest these past few years have been
tough
and these past few months have been
tougher i have been tried with some of
the biggest unimaginable tests of my
life
i am currently now unemployed and i left
my job partly due to afflictions
he also spoke on facebook about the end
times and the antichrist on march 17th
he posted a photo of a donation he made
to the norfolk virginia chapter of the
nation of islam
along with a video of farrakhan's speech
entitled the divine destruction of
america
later that day he encouraged his friends
to join him in studying the teachings of
farrakhan and mr muhammad
the nation of islam is a black
nationalist movement that has advocated
african-american self-sufficiency
all right i've got i've got a thread
pulled up from andy know who's dug
in a little bit to who this guy is and
some of the things he said
and i want to point out something the
way the new york times is
quoting this guy as if we're going to
look at his statements
not that long ago it was a police
officer who was paraphrasing
what a mass shooter had said and he
lost his job basically for this he was
attacked they accused him of placating
this this evil man
why is the new york times what's with
the double standard
we get it though we see the double
standard all the time the mainstream
establishment corporate press and
politicians are deferential to left-wing
extremism
they would come out with in in seconds
condemning this and saying everything
you'd expect him to say
terror ban guns all that stuff if this
actually was
a white person as we've often seen this
time though
many of these people did come out they
did say that now they're gonna
become very quiet that we're learning
now that we're learning who the suspect
is
that's exactly what happened with uh
with uh with boulder
in fact now andy noe posts about the the
suspect here and i just want to point
out uh one of
a couple other things he says in his
last instagram post before the attack he
wrote
the us government is the number one
enemy of black people
we are very much seeing leftist
identitarianism
and it's reaching extreme levels when it
comes to antifa and black lives matter
we've long seen what i refer to as like
blunt force
extremism in that the attacks they
engaged in
weren't the the most violent most
violent or most lethal
but they were consistent and there were
several instances of them so when when
these riots start and they burn down
buildings they cause massive destruction
the loss of life is extensive across the
country
but the media as i mentioned deferential
when it comes to
these these mass shooters these are high
profile very acute instances
where everyone's attention is is just
grabbed instantly
so when you're dealing with endless
anti-fun black lives matter violence
but the on average you know they're
punching people and they're beating
people that stuff doesn't become
national news now as things become
hyper-polarized
this may be a one-off and hopefully this
is just some some sick man and that's
the end of it
but it may be that things are going to
get even worse from this i know maybe
it's a bit pessimistic for me to say
but i can already see the demands that
we ban guns over this
that we reinstate security around the
capital lock it down send to the
national guard
now a lot of these people are saying
this before they realized this shooter
was actually a black nationalist but we
have this tweet from
reptilian omar she said the death toll
would have been worse if the assailant
had an ar-15 instead of a knife
just completely unrelated to what
happened
but there's already efforts from many
people
to weaponize this so i don't know what
you guys think it's it's always hard to
kind of segue into a conversation we're
dealing with such serious
uh news topics and you know kind of this
hyperpolarization but
i suppose considering you know we've all
talked about this i'm curious your
thoughts julie on
the hyper polarization the conflict
security state and you know everything's
been going on
sure i think there's absolutely a double
standard you know a few weeks ago when
that guy who happened to be white
shot up the atlanta spas people
automatically said oh this is a white
supremacist terrorist
ma maybe we don't know but they were
quick to jump on that
we don't really know his intentions
maybe he was a sex addict we don't know
if he was asian or not
asian if it's just like him going after
these women for
being women and tempting him we don't
know but as soon as he did it it was
like white supremacist
terrorist but now this guy who
is we know is a nation of islam which is
a black supremacist
very racist group like everyone thinks
they're racist that's not a
controversial thing
this guy went to the capitol with a
knife he killed a police officer
and they're saying oh there's no
terrorism there's no we
see no evidence of terrorism like it's
been a few
hours people like what did you have to
investigate that
spend a few minutes maybe yeah they're
just oh well he was islam
he was the nation of islam guy so
therefore it's not terrorism we don't
want to like offend people you know we
don't want to
say you know make people uncomfortable
with like
what it's the future flowers you know
what's interesting is uh when
when that when that tragedy happened in
atlanta
the i believe it was the police i'm not
sure they said it wasn't race related
right so here's what i find interesting
they came out and said no no it wasn't
he was a sex addict two of the victims
were white but even you point out we we
don't really know we need an
investigation
a lot of people on the left immediately
said it was a race thing
even when when the police come out and
say it's not now
i know uh well maybe maybe it's a bit
unfair for me to say this but i'll
speculate and i'd be willing to bet on
this
the left is immediately gonna change
their tune and say it wasn't terror it
was a disturbed young man and that's the
game they'll play
unless they want to ban guns you know i
i think it's it's ridiculous that ilhan
omar was like what if he had a gun
what if he had a tank i don't know it's
ridiculous this is a tragedy
you can speculate whatever you want but
they're gonna they're gonna do it
because
it's an excuse to gain power absolutely
but he had a knife
he brought a knife to a gun fight he got
killed that was
dumb it was a poor strategy could it be
suicide by cop it's possible did he ram
he rammed somebody with his car
is that right i guess he rammed through
the barricade yeah oh i see
yeah yeah so he's the car and a knife
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what gets
me about this this georgia thing is with
georgia is that where he the guy
murdered
six in the in the spas yeah like they'll
do
if they're gonna do like tests or like
investigations and then in a year
and a month they're like okay we figured
out he was racist we figured out
he wasn't racist like what difference
does it make that guy murdered six
people
he was deranged eight people i think
eight people yeah
it's yeah it was terrifying you want to
call it terror or not terror
it it was terrifying for those people it
may be maybe it wasn't political
terror what's the difference man this is
i i agree
it's like hate crimes right where
they're like we're gonna we're gonna
investigate your your
thought process before you commit a
crime it's like dude hitting someone's
illegal
like the reason why you did it you did
it you know what i mean the action is
illegal
i can't read your mind and they try to
infer
as to as to what you were thinking one
of the biggest reasons i have a problem
with terror laws
and hate crime laws is that they're
going to be selectively used
in this instance already saying it
wasn't terror well dude was a black
nationalist who posted on instagram that
the american government is the enemy of
black people
what's are you kidding me and they're
going to be like no look i don't care if
they do or don't just keep it consistent
i think this guy committed a crime
that's enough let me see if i got this
straight
so this guy was on facebook and
instagram posting about how much he
hated the us government
and then he went to washington dc and
rammed into the capital fence
and they're calling this definitely not
terrorism
that's an act of police is that what i'm
yeah it is an act of political terror
i'm not i don't support these like
terror laws where you throw people in
gitmo because of the way they were
thinking when they did the crime
right he's from indiana he went to dc
was he in dc for was he in school
i don't know statement yes are you sure
maybe why would you go to dc that's a
good point lydia yeah that's what i was
thinking so glenn glenn greenwald called
this out we have this post from politico
the suspect was not known to capitol
police or dc police officials said
robert conti the acting dc police chief
said the incident does not appear to be
terrorism-related and there was no
indication of a nexus to a member of
congress
glenn greenwald responded on what basis
did the police pronounce the capital
attack does not appear to be terror
uh terrorism related how was it remotely
possible to determine the mode of the
attacker
this early which by the way is what
determines whether an act of violence is
or is not terror
politics it's politics yeah
how long did it take before they finally
banned uh fair con off all these social
media platforms
i wasn't following i don't know they got
rid of
all the white nationalists farrakhan was
allowed to stay on
twitter allowed him to say things that
were overtly anti-semitic and he's a
supremacist
uh racial supremacist just happens to be
the difference if you if you took
quotes from farrakhan and in any
instance of the word black you just
swapped out white you'd probably
confuse people because they think it was
hitler because absolutely
yeah and and so i'll say this he should
be allowed to be on twitter he should be
allowed to say what he wants to say good
because when he was saying this stuff we
all saw it and now
when the new york times brings it up we
know it and when we see the suspect
we know what he believed in who he
followed and that's creepy
creepy stuff good to know yeah
absolutely but think about what happens
when they ban this guy
the only reason the new york times is
like they repeatedly promoted
anti-semitism is because the news
stories that erupted
when farrakhan would post these things
or when these videos would come out
you get rid of that speech you get rid
of that you know that ability to share
information
and we'd be wondering like who's
farrakhan i don't know what this is
it was a religious fellow i think racist
should expose themselves let them talk
we'll judge them hold them accountable
but yeah don't ban them from
stuff i want to see what they want to
say you know i think the issue though is
that
these like the ultra woke people they're
the racists
you know they and they do a really good
job of masquerading as the not racists
you know going around telling everybody
that they're anti-racist they got they
got that book was it anti-racist baby
oh yeah kids books that are being made
and tell the kids how to be a you know
cult member and things like that
well they go around naming their cult
anti-racists and it reminds me of the
simpsons
when uh homer is telling the story about
when he's a kid
and they had the no homer's club and
then he's like but you let in that other
home
like we're allowed to have one like they
made the name specifically to address
something they were you know didn't want
anti-racist and then they go around
literally discriminating based on race
and encouraging overt hardcore
unitarianism and anti-semitism
and i'm just like man the there's so
many well-to-do liberals
that are so obsessed with social justice
narratives they overlook the fact that
black nationalist anti-semites exist
in large numbers with a massive
following and they're sitting here going
like
but what about trump supporters what
about him we're going to wave a little
american flag around i get it the people
at the capitol there's a decent amount
of people that went crazy and stormed
the capital that was bad
but you compare that to everything we've
seen and the strength of the movement
from things like uh you know farrakhan
it's just not even a question but that
stuff's just
they ignore all that this actually seems
to be a prevalent thing in the
african-american community because if
you look at the attacks
well if you look at the attacks on
jewish people in new york city
a majority of them are done by a certain
ethnic minority
i know i know i know you can't say it
but you can look at the videos and you
can be like oh my gosh this is like
actually a problem in their community
and i wonder if that is the influence of
um the you know the nation of islam i
don't know i'm not
sorry i think that's why the atlanta
spa shooting got so much outrage because
it was a white dude and i think they
were secretly
happy that it was a white person to say
oh these white people hate asian people
honestly i've never met a white person
that hates asian people i love asian
people
i wish they would move in next to me i
want my kid to go to their schools i
love asian people
i think it could be a problem in the
black community
i've heard there's tensions between the
agents moving in and having like stores
and like
liquor stores and convenience stores and
they think they're taking away
they're making profits off the black
people i don't know that's not my
community but i've heard there's tension
there but they want to focus on oh these
white people hate asian people
i don't think that's really a huge thing
it's
when you look at the rules of
youtube facebook instagram twitter etc
etc
you're allowed to disparage white people
yeah yeah like outright like they've
even talked about how
i think i can't remember which platform
it was they said you know
you you're allowed to make disparaging
comments on traditionally
non-marginalized groups of people or
whatever like we know what that means
and so you know thinking back to like
old comedy
it was always safe to be like oh okay
white people you know
people crazy yeah you can make fun of
them and i understand
the the the the idea behind it right the
left would tell you was like oh there's
white privilege
yeah and because of that you're punching
up which is fine but punching down is
wrong
but that means because of these rules
you can't have very real conversations
that are that are important
you mentioned the gentrification problem
that's absolutely
very prominent within left-wing activist
circles
and uh within black lives matter for ins
and to clarify too
what asian means in many of these
communities is not like chinese or
japanese
it's indian as well it's middle eastern
so when i was in ferguson
they burned down a gas station during
the michael brown riots
and i interviewed some of the people
there why did you burn down this gas
station you know they said
because the asian guy comes here and he
buys a gas station in our neighborhood
why is he making money off of us he
doesn't live here
so they burn it down we broadcast that
that was on vice
that's on youtube i mean i don't know if
they still have it up but that's what
they said
so there's very much racial tensions
when i was in milwaukee
during uh black lives matter rioting
they straight up where yelling get the
white people f the white people
and an 18 year old white he got shot in
the neck i grew up
watching this stuff and it's no surprise
to me but i'm curious you know
when i mentioned that i did i did a
video saying i wasn't going to be
covering what was going on in milwaukee
at the time because
of the racial tensions and i was like
for someone they perceive to be white
it's dangerous you know this kid got
shot in the neck so i'm i'm not going to
stick around
it's remarkable i did that video because
i think i had like 20 000 subscribers
and there are people who follow me and
they wanted me to post videos from what
was going on in the ground and i said
i'm not gonna do it and here's why and
it was just to my followers well the
video ended up going viral and getting
shared by a bunch of conservatives who
are like oh look at this this is
you know proof of something and the left
was like tim poole only did that to
grift
i'm like to who my 20 000 followers who
i know and follow and comment
yeah this is it's crazy yeah you make
money well but
yeah right but it's it's insane how like
these things are real
and these racial tensions exist and
there's absolutely racism
in the black community in the asian
community in in the latino community in
the white community
towards each other as well oh definitely
i mean asians
oh my gosh hispanic people talk about
each other it's
just gossip yeah but i don't know
yeah so i feel like there's kind of like
i feel like we're in a cultural
uh the left is in a cultural mexican
standoff
yeah where they're all just there's just
like piranhas everywhere these these
culture warriors
ready to cancel you the moment you say
something that's cancelable
so no one will have honest conversations
about their communities or other
communities or racism
because they'll get canceled the moment
they do i hope i get cancelled though
because dr
seuss got cancelled and his books are up
i have children's books i hope i get
cancelled so i can go top
yeah amazon what are your what are your
children's books i have two children's
books
it's a first one is nobody knows how to
make a pizza it's based on littered
reads eye pencil
but i made it for kids about pizza
awesome but it talks about you know
division of labor
spontaneous order all those economics oh
cool yeah
so there's no central planner making
this pizza it's people all over the
world
doing the tomatoes and the cheese yeah
yeah because there's no one person who
grows tomatoes
farms dairy yeah yeah oregano and then
brings all together with sugar
it's all different farms and yeah yeah
do you think pizza is really simple but
it's it's really complicated
yeah yeah i wonder if uh somewhere
someone's actually
decided to make a pizza farm like let me
just make all the things we got cows we
got tomatoes i think you guys could do
[Laughter]
it's a it of work for pizza yeah and
then you also i'll
going back to the more serious
conversation i suppose the left is all
they're all staring at each other and
they i feel like most these people
actually let me stop leaked video came
out i just saw this on twitter a teacher
one of these teachers in la and you know
they do this woke stuff
apparently forgot to turn off zoom and
then went on like a racist tirade
about this other this other black family
and the way that she perceived black
people and the way they acted
it was it was crazy to hear this and
people are sharing this being like these
are the people
teaching your kids woke critical race
theory trash overtly racist
they know they're racist they're
pretending not to be racist but they're
super racist
and then it's really funny because
you'll get black lives matter being like
yo these white people are racist
and we're like stop saying everyone's
racist but they're literally pointing to
these like
urban leftist you know critical race
theorist people too
and i'm like yeah okay well you know
they're racist yeah for sure that's
that's
that's what they're like behind the
scenes and they don't say it so i feel
like they're all sitting there like it's
like that uh kean peel
segment where there's where he's
sweating like crazy just like standing
there
and that's what all the like many of
these racist leftists are doing
waiting for one person to just say the
wrong word
we mix in an ex how dare you that's
offensive women
got you now and all just hitting each
other so they don't have any real
conversations about stuff
i think it's i think it's intentional
i've been today has been very exhausting
in that if you look at what's happening
across the world when we'll probably
talk about later crimea
um in china with hong kong and taiwan uh
russia and ukraine
like now they have the americans all
stuck in this paralyzed fear state
so like we're not going to get involved
that's what they want if there's going
to be an invasion of
of crimea and ukraine by the russians an
invasion of taiwan and hong kong by
chinese they don't want the united
states to react in a cohesive manner
and if this is the stuff we're focused
on we're not going to bingo
yeah it feels like in many ways the
establishment
has just decided okay wokeness is our is
our path i suppose
which it feels that way because from the
intelligence agencies to the military
even the embracing like the chief
diversity
officer or whatever the pentagon are you
kidding me
why would there be a movement an effort
in the federal government to
divide this country
why would why would the americans be
intentionally dividing themselves
it could either be outside influence or
it could be a form of like
cultural apoptosis where like one cell
is no longer needed in a system it
destroys itself so like if the united
states has become vestigial
if in the human experience that we're
just we're just ending our own
experience
for us i don't i don't think so i would
say this
if this is the case uh we're conquered
exactly
but okay listen people say oh i hate
division i hate division i want
to be unified but people i think
secretly
love division i make commentary
if i make it very divisive people will
eat that
up people love to see their enemies
you know we talk yeah
to own the libs we got to own the libs
and all that
i think people like the vision i think
they'd like to see their enemies hurting
they want war they want conflict of some
sort because people people strive for
words
they want something yeah but our we're
supposed to own the communists
it's supposed to be like own the commies
you know make that anti-commie stuff and
then make fun of the communists and the
concentration camps instead were ripping
at each other
so if if these other countries engage in
some kind of conflict if we really do
escalate in the south china sea or or in
eastern europe
the us is everyone's fighting each other
so
i guess the point i'm trying to make is
we need to be like hey everyone in
america we come together and we respect
each other
we're all americans first we're not this
race first or this identity first
instead the the prevailing ideology
that's infected all of our institutions
from the news media to schools and now
the military
is divide everybody up based on
immutable characteristics and some other
self-identified characteristics so that
we are as fractured as possible
okay i'm sorry like any strategist is
going to be like that's a terrible idea
so then when conflict arises we're too
busy fighting ourselves
you know they want in as infantry they
want you like an infant
they want your mind clear they don't
want you to have
all this social order don't don't pull
an aoc on me
there's a surge of the border they're
not insurgents they're infantile
they want to wipe your mind clean of
your past identity and make a new one
that is
synonymous with all others and that's
why you're part of this infant
this is
the people who are fighting in a
conflict who are unified who know
who who's on their side and knows what
they're fighting for and often we have
corrupt officials and and institutions
and
uh governments that manipulate the the
good will of the people who are willing
to fight and lay their lives down for
for the right cause they get manipulated
and they get exploited and that's kind
of what america's been doing for quite
some time especially in the past several
decades
but uh but but i i have tremendous
respect for those that are willing to do
that the problem is the
the corrupted system more importantly
however
when i when i see the pentagon chief
diversity officer and he got cancelled
because he had racist comments or
something i don't know amazing like
we're
we're we're infected you know what i
mean like we're fractured there's not
coming back from this is there
no you can't convince the cultist to to
abandon the cult they're going coming
back from this we altered
globe the way humans will interact
forever yeah i thought maybe a silver
lining of covid was like people coming
together
you know no the complete opposite of
that happened
we had a common enemy here kovit and
still
nope what i absolutely love about the
covet thing too in terms of division is
that conservatives initially were like
you should wear a mask and it was fauci
and the surgeon general who were like no
no no and conservatives were like don't
listen
don't listen and then it switched and
then what happened
now the conservatives are the ones who
are like apple
and and the left is like where three i
was consistent on that okay there you go
there you go with the cdc and foster was
saying oh don't wear it don't wear a
mask there's no need to i was saying
you are liars you can check my twitter
were you selling gadsden flag masks i
was selling the book later
later later okay and then they switched
their mind
it was really because they didn't want
people to hoard masks they were liars
and that was terrible because now people
are not
listening to them on vaccines or
anything because they're liars
however i still said hey wearing a mask
is a good idea
fauci admitted this uh in an interview
he said
we didn't want people to buy up all the
masks when the professionals needed him
first
yeah so they're a bunch of liars but now
there's a lot to a libertarian say oh
you're
you believe in these government
conspiracies because you want to wear a
mask it's like man i'm consistent on
this issue
like i'm not a child they're such a
juvenile
thing like if the government says
something i'm gonna do the opposite well
a lot of times that is true but not
all the time like use your brain not
just like
reactionary juvenile i got i got hit up
by somebody
when all this started going down with
kovid and they were like yo the
government said you don't need masks
quick buy a bunch
and i'm like is it you know what man
it's it's it's so predictable
a bunch of the libertarian type people i
know are like i don't trust the
government they're saying don't i better
buy one
and then when the government says to do
and they're like you can't tell me what
to do yeah no
it's like duh okay it's called
obstinates
yes it is very dangerous you can't tell
me
yeah now i'll tell you that like i
tweeted where 12 masks and it got like 3
000 retweets
yes i just wear 12. and people were like
i don't know 13. it's like look i picked
an arbitrary number that was stupid yeah
you know i actually have an idea we
should do this for like a bonus thing
for the website
just put on as many mass as we can see
how many we can find yeah i just keep
playing
breathing i can't keep going that's huge
yeah i don't know you might get to a
point where you're like too many
yeah like 12 might be the limit i
suppose your elbows on your
i mean your ears or have gas canals in
them too do you need to mask your ears
as well got to cover your eyes no just
your mouth
just nose put a pillow case over your
head there you go you can still breathe
through it
you know then you're saying i saw a
commercial for those big space man
helmets
yeah they're like really taking it
seriously oh gosh of course they are
we have it right put your money where
your mouth is julie here you go yeah you
put it on
oh yeah you're going to be healthier
when that's over don't
you don't have to put you know you're
going to talk i was really going to do
it
it's just infinitely more comfortable
wearing the space helmet than it is
i will say as much as goofy as i think
it is it's not uncomfortable i mean it
is uncomfortable because it's picking
heavy on i gotta be honest
yeah i'm gonna wear that you know why i
got allergies yeah yeah it's got like a
hepa filter or whatever
two of them i can walk around outside
and i won't sneeze
and y'all be jealous we're displaying
the best all right and dude my allergies
are bad man it's like
yeah because all the trees are exploding
and it's basically you're getting all
this
this tree spunk up in your business
sugar and stop it it does help that
helps yeah i like it
my allergies are gone i used to get
horrible uh pollen allergies i start
drinking water cut out soda
water yep yeah and i'm no longer i'm
allergic to pollen i can smell it if i
take a huge whiff of pollen i'll feel it
tickle the back of my throat still
but it's like dehydration it dehydrates
the nasal folds
so i drink water it kind of absorbs the
pollen i read on this website
that if you eat worms like parasites
then you'll get cured of your allergies
maybe it maybe it was just one of those
crackpot hippie dippy websites
but what it was saying was that actually
i probably saw this on reddit because i
don't read any crackpot hippie dippy
websites
but uh uh it was basically saying that
you have two different immune systems i
suppose one for parasites and one for
pathogens or something
no interesting but because we've cured
ourselves and like
limited parasites for the most part from
our diets we just have this like crazy
immune system
that could just be a bunch of bunk
nonsense from reddit probably
i don't know maybe someone knows better
so they can try it no not me
but uh you know back in the day they
used to like like die like tape worms
for diets
you would like take the pills is that
true that's true i think so i'm i i
looked that up yeah yeah and it was like
tape worms well you'll lose weight quick
they used to bleed people to try and
heal them of illness
cut do you remember that product
from like the 2000s where you would take
a pill
and then you couldn't digest fat yeah
and you just crap it out i remember that
so maybe was that um i remember a lot of
diet pills in the
80s and it's like you would your it
would cause your body to not digest fat
and so you would just like expel it it
was like dex something
yeah yeah i don't know
i think
something earlier that i thought was
kind of profound is that people need
conflict
i do think they need conflicts i think
people secretly like conflict
yeah it's like uh have you guys seen
wonder woman
not the new one the new one with the gal
gadot no no not no
not 1984 like the good one that came out
the actual good one
where so that's basically it like she
thinks that if she defeats the god of
war aries
the war will stop and then chris pine's
character is like dude people
fight man like there's conflict you
can't do anything about it
and then it's like ares all he does is
whisper in the ear he doesn't make the
war
he just you know nudges people in the
right direction to you know excite that
conflict
and like if he wasn't around and it just
built and built and built then it might
explode into some
some giant gorilla con i'm going to move
this girl but some giant like
life-ending conflicts so maybe a little
bit of conflict frequently
is healthier than letting it build up
it didn't just automatically ah yeah
just
a little bit relation i mean that's part
of why relationships i think are like
yeah
you know you're married yes that's being
in being in relationships a lot of like
people love that you know what i found
today
the rage rooms are coming where you go
into a room
you break stuff yes it's kind of like
you know escape rooms are kind of thing
there's rage room now where you have a
hammer and they let you break whatever
you want in this room
interesting so you get some stress out
yeah that would
cover related stress yeah yeah that's
fine i think it's cool
i play a lot of games to get my my
conflict resolution out of my system
sometimes but it's not not really
physical it's mostly mental
i didn't i didn't know about this rage
room yeah that's fascinating yeah we got
this i just pulled this up from
nbc why a rage room might be the key to
venting your bottled frustration
but rage rooms are not appropriate
treatment for everybody no i i couldn't
handle that
that's crazy to me that's making money
worse yeah yeah i would not enjoy
breaking stuff and like going out like
that
really yeah i kind of would i don't know
okay you know everybody
everybody's got their own different way
of doing things they actually say about
catharsis that it's not necessarily good
it can make things worse
you know one of the things that i'm
starting to wonder during the course of
this conversation is that maybe
because we're not in relationships we're
not married and we don't have families
we don't want to break i mean yeah it's
not that you don't want to break stuff
but you don't have like the rock tumbler
effect of being in a long-term
relationship where you're just kind of
like knocking the rough edges off the
other person constantly and they're
doing the same for you and maybe that
leads to our
emotions being bottled up and yelling at
each other no i i was just i was just
thinking that
um because of something you said earlier
when you are talking about just being
busy with your family
because it's something we've absolutely
heard from a lot of other guests and a
lot of our friends where it's like
oh man you know with the school like
we've been so wrapped up i haven't been
following the news all that much you
know because i got two kids or whatever
that's what i hear a lot of
and so i'm thinking right now you know
what would end the culture war
seriously just end the protest make some
babies yeah get something to do
because then they would have no choice
but to be wrapped up in family yeah
and something else matters just your
family yeah they'd be productive they'd
be working and they'd be occupied
yeah idle hands are the devil's
playground but i suppose we should say
idol nethers yes are the devil's
playground
funny get it done yeah that's right no
but i i guess that's not the issue i
think you know people
actually know that is the issue yeah
yeah i was gonna say maybe people are
still hooking up
but they're not they're not having
babies no no no no they're not even
hooking up that's true too yeah yeah
yeah like overwhelmingly gen z
is just like a bunch of prudes
no no no they can't yeah i think of
chemical castration not really
castration but like
all these weird new food chemicals that
get added and created in laboratories
you know all these new sugars sucralose
aspartame high fructose and and yeah
that's making people's sex drive go down
we've heard testosterone
yeah but but ian to a hammer everything
looks like a nail and so you go out you
go on these things about sugar
and then you make the assumption that
these things relate to these other
problems
when if you actually look at the data
the reason for this has a lot to do with
social media
and dating websites poor
dating in the uk is it really yeah what
happened crime
you can't have sex in the uk it's
illegal what what it is
let me let me repeat this it is a crime
in the uk
to have sex with a person including brit
all the commonwealth unless you're in a
relationship with him i think
oh wow yeah i'm pretty sure i think what
carl benjamin
this is headline news what is happening
are they enforcing that
right seriously i saw where they
suggested yeah
yeah reuters it's from june 2nd
this is from last year british
government faces mockery or chronovirus
sex ban
yeah yeah oh there you go god
for keeping people safe under amendments
introducing english rules on monday no
person may participate in a gathering
which takes place in public or private
and consists of two or more persons
britain britain's tabloid media casted
as the bonking ban
what this is about making sure we don't
have people staying away from home at
night
uh-huh so two or more people so
two people can't be alone together
that's what they're saying legally yeah
yeah i mean this is like look at this
like the google thing yeah yeah
october reuters uk banned sex between
government aid workers
october 16th sex ban england's coveted
tears october 25th uk's sex
ban explained june 4th coronavirus sex
ban
dude it is like the uk 2021 has gone
like fur
fuel has gone full there we go
full sex for you no sex wow
jeez can you imagine if like joe biden
came out and was like
my fellow americans we're making sex
illegal
they'd be right come on man there'd be
riots huge riots
dude this is so it's creepy isn't it
that is dystopian it's it's i mean i'm
i'm i'm
shattered [ __ ]
it might sound hyperbolic i'm not
literally i don't think i'm shattered
but my dna is shattering
yeah like i feel shaken with this news
of
of russia in ukraine and then this
social war thing is like
i don't know what to do i could have
sworn i read something that
was sent to me by carl benjamin where it
was like the uk says you can't have sex
with somebody
and then also it's just like some
high-ranking government officials
telling people to just go
like crank it out themselves oh that's
right you know i read some good
recommendations where you're supposed to
watch your partner jerk off in front of
you
but not get close to him or for yeah
that was a
recommendation from the government
that's weird we're not family friendly
on friday night
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry guys no i mean
i i i brought it
yeah but i mean it's it's like
the ultimate authoritarianism i suppose
that if
we're like social media is a problem
it's it's making young people not have
family and then suddenly we're like and
then they have no purpose
yes it's true you know what's really
funny is because i don't have kids
see it's my own fault i've been talking
about how
millennials and the the these
generations have no purpose
so i did this video a while back about
you know how jordan p
peterson provided purpose to many young
men find the heaviest thing you can
carry and carry it
and then wokeness was the purpose for
these leftists
so you have these young people who are
sitting there like why am i alive
and then like hitting themselves in the
head screaming and so they searched for
anything
and some people found wokeness it's
almost it's almost like you guys are
watching underworld
yeah no you've never seen it you know
where like the the
the corvid what is it called the court
venus
yeah yeah it's like basically this
dude's got this like immortality thing
and then one son's bitten by a bat and
one son's bitten by a wolf and then it
creates the two different tribes the
werewolves and the vampires
so you have these people who like drift
into one tribe or the other sjw anti-sjw
because they're trying to find some
purpose in their lives and
you know like like i mentioned jordan
peterson provided purpose to a lot of
these young men
left absolutely hated it but then i
realized that
you know my perspective was lacking
because i don't have kids
the real purpose missing from these
people's lives is family yes
just outright the the people before
these generations
didn't have idle hands weren't desperate
for a purpose
they had kids they had like 10 kids yeah
yeah my great-grandmother had 12
kids i'm like whoa how do you do that
you know it's crazy now it's frowned
upon yeah
how's your life changing like how what
how different is it what what
what have you has your social perception
changed since you've been raising a
family or raising children
a child uh the world scares the crap out
of me
what aspects of it just
what kind of future my son is going to
be into
and how can i change that and i think
i've changed my commentary a lot
um where i've been you know i want to
make a difference
a positive difference in people's lives
where before you know i was a little bit
trolly i'm still a little bit trolly
but i feel like i want to make an impact
in the world because for my son
and hopefully future children's sake i'm
also
scared of pedophiles oh yeah i feel like
there's so many out there creepy people
the absolute the abstinent thing was a
conspiracy theory it was a conspiracy
theory for years
and alex jones was mocked relentlessly
for talking about these things
and then mike cernovich and a reporter
in from i think the miami herald i'm not
sure started
filing lawsuits they i think they then
joined i could begin the story wrong but
they were both very much going after
these files and then
all of a sudden it was like boom this is
real
this happened you know the documents
were there and you were called crazy if
you said that these high-profile people
like harvey weinstein for instance
granted he's a bit different but still
these like ex like
these are extreme instances of severe
predation
and you were a conspiracy theorist it
wasn't true even though
like the crazy things like seth
macfarlane family guy jokes
would make fun of kevin spacey and
harvey weinstein and you were wondering
like what do these people
actually know in these industries so so
so definitely but i also wonder if i
don't know just
what can you do for your son's future
you know what i mean let me let me get
more um
nuanced i hear a lot from people who
have kids where they're like i have to
make sure i'm around for my kids
but then they're willing to sacrifice
the bigger picture for the for the for
for their kids you know what i mean like
they're willing to say i'll forego this
conflict and risking myself to fight
for these ideas because it's better that
i can be there for my kids to give them
food
than it is that i defend the future yeah
so i don't know what yeah what's what do
you think what are you gonna do you seem
to be am i gonna do
yeah are you gonna talk about it i'm
pretty much a stay-at-home mom
i think i sacrificed some stuff to be a
stay-at-home mom but i think it's
absolutely worth it
i think i heard an interview before from
a hospice nurse
and she said what is people's biggest
regret on their death beds
and they say i didn't spend enough time
with my family
she said she'd always heard it from men
but in recent years she's heard it more
for women
who chose to have a career
and you know send their kids off to
daycare and i understand some people
have to do that
some people do not have the financial
means i understand that i am privileged
in that
sense however if i have the option to be
a stay-at-home mom
and be there with my kids then i will
take that
so i think that i i it's worth it i
think just
that i have influence over my child and
isn't just a stranger who's raising them
whose
ideology i may not agree with and who
may be
out of his life and i'm always going to
be there
i was going to ask are you going to send
him to public school that's a decision
we have not made
yet okay um but he's only three
i am homeschooling him i suppose even
though
yeah he's learning his colors and
numbers and the dinosaurs
he knows quite a few of them have you
given him any
skateboards should give him a skateboard
he actually has a scooter
all right i guess he has like a dinosaur
helmet with spikes
nice i like that that's punk yeah yeah
it was it was crazy
uh you know growing up skateboarding
there would always be these scooter kids
at the skate park and skateboarders were
so annoyed because they'd get in the way
and didn't know what they were doing
but i'll tell you the craziest thing is
like i see the scooter kid at the
skatepark
and i'm like oh these scooter kids man
like they're always in the way i get it
they're kids they're here they're
playing it's fine but their parents got
to tell them about like teaching about
etiquette and stuff
then it's like four years later and the
scooter kid is now like 15 and he's
doing backflips and like
launching you know 10 feet in the end
i'm like damn
the scooter kid's good now this is rad
like now it's fun to watch
so yeah scooter is cool no i think
definitely physical activity mental
activity
and i'd say dude if it were me don't put
them in school man
it's tough that having having having
your kid
understand the system from within it is
probably really important
but it can only be done with your
guidance outside of the school
absolutely like for me i went to grade
school and they you know they fill your
head with complete bunk garbage
and then i would go home and have my mom
be like that's not true it set you
straight yeah and then i was like oh
and then i realized like i realized what
the system was and
sort of i was very young but i was like
oh okay so this is not entirely
legitimate
and so i would see how the system worked
but was constantly being reminded from
outside of it what the system was
also i started working for my family's
business when i was like 9 or 10 years
old
because we had a family we had a family
cafe and then you hear real
conversations from real adults you deal
with real money and you have real
experience in the real world
you go to school and everything's so
trivial and nonsensical you know
yeah i think parental involvement is
number one i grew up going to government
schools but i had a family who's more
conservative
my grandfather was a huge influence on
me he was
more of a libertarian type and he would
tell me you know
just kiss their butt get an a and then
just everything they say go out the
other ear
that's good that's good oh yeah it is a
lot like military
academy like public school sit down wait
for the bell to ring raise your hand
don't speak out of line
you know stand up uh the dress some
places have dress codes
i wonder if sending kids off to military
school at the age of four or five
is wise i don't know about military
school pre-military school let's call it
like pre-k
no i think having uh uh the parents
a good balance between between masculine
feminine
and physical activity and and mental
activity
having a a strong father and mother who
can provide
a good balance of you know perspective
suppose not everybody gets that though
you got to be lucky are you going to
have a dad who's like a short overweight
middle manager who
is deferential to everybody and just
whenever someone pushes him around he
apologizes and tells his kid to keep his
head down and not fight back
or is he gonna be this like ripped
lumberjack guy who's like don't take
nothing from nobody
and then he like here's your shotgun i
know you're seven but i think you can
handle a 12-gauge son
and then you gotta have the mom being
like don't give him a 12-gauge when he's
seven you gotta have that mix you know
what i mean
yeah you gotta give him the 410. come on
man start small
give a kid a gun that big geez no i
don't know i think
you know it's tough especially now
because millennials aren't having kids
they lack purpose and there seems to be
a in my opinion dangerous cultural shift
that has nothing to do with tradition
or progression you know uh it's not
about being progressive or being a
traditionalist it's about
i mean humans have kids you know what i
mean that's our purpose yeah
i mean it's it's i don't know if it's
purpose but um
i know like when you have kids your kids
become your purpose
and that if you don't have kids humanity
ceases to exist
your culture chooses to exist here's
what's fascinating to me
when i hear from liberals and their
attitude is very much
who cares if america ceases to exist
have you ever heard the sentiment from
these from liberals like you see mine
you said on twitter
they'll they'll take like a a quote from
a conservative who's like you have to
have kids to preserve america and its
culture
and they'll be like why
and that's why it's really fascinating
to see conservatives this overlaps a lot
with like immigration yeah
concern about immigrants coming in and
displacing american american culture and
getting rid of christmas
conservatives very much want to preserve
you know conserve
these traditions and their culture i'm
actually
not particularly conservative i just
think if you don't have kids then
there's no
people so i mean i guess we can build
robots to replace ourselves we're not
doing that either
or live longer we live to be 200 then we
don't we need to have like
40 percent as many children or something
maybe it's like what you were saying ian
was it apoptosis yeah
that's for real man it's like the the
mice the mouse utopia
you get to a certain point where you're
just consuming and doing nothing and
just
before the roman empire crumbled
basically a lot of homosexuality started
or
homosexuality spiked i believe and there
was just a lot
less making babies i don't know they
were living in like the age of gluttony
pretty much they had everything they
didn't care they didn't want to serve in
the military anymore because
that they might lose what they had and
they they loved their things
and um then they got conquered from from
the outside
yeah yeah i think you know people
mention a lot the the mouse utopia
have you heard of that they basically
created the space where they put a bunch
of mice or rats or something and they
gave them all food and said
like no matter what happened they never
ran out of food they never they never
ran out of food or water
and so they eventually just like some
stopped eating
some started eating others some just
stopped reproducing and just died
and you know people wonder if we as
humans are susceptible to something
similar where
we've reached this point where people
don't have to work
and i mean it when you've got somebody
who lives in new york city
and their job is to write articles for
buzzfeed i'm sorry
that's not work it's not work work is
like
i have to grow the food i have to hunt i
have to build the house i have to start
the fire i have to generate the
electricity to power the machines i have
to find the energy source
so that we can stay warm in the winter
writing articles about celebrity gossip
is not work
oh they'll say it's so isn't that a good
thing though like i look
back i'm a woman obviously but my great
grandfathers were coal miners and so
much
hard work i i look back at my my great
grandmother's like they had to cook
everything from scratch and wash
everything from
you know they have laundry machines or
dishwashers and
i just i think we're so lucky to not
have to do all that stuff
going going back yes and so i'll attach
you down to what ian was saying about we
were talking about rome right
yeah or greece well the roman ru both
probably yeah i think there's a lot of
vanity and gluttony at the end of both
of those here's what i see
when the the culture
is stagnant you know uh or
if the technology isn't fast enough and
if
you know it's a weird hybrid moment of
reaching that apex of technology with
population
to where the culture stagnates then once
rome collapsed the technology persisted
a lot of this information persisted and
spread out a little bit
and then started to improve and people
started to fight again and work hard
again
and then you get you you know you come
to the colonial era european
uh colonialism and things like that
striving for more and no longer just
being like i want to be a lay about
glutton because i have all this stuff
so the technology remains things become
easier but then the quest reemerges
so maybe what's going to happen for us
is that some kind of
you know mass massive you know
century turning or millennial turning
millennium
turning where we've reached this point
where we as a culture
are all gluttonous because technology
has granted us this
after our culture collapses then there
will be a struggle again
but that technology will still exist so
then in another couple hundred years
it'll be even better for everybody and
then they'll start becoming gluttonous
and lazy you know what i mean
i guess the question is do we have it
too good in america
because my my father-in-law was from the
soviet union
and he you know he wasn't such a great
time in the soviet union he's like looks
at these american kids and teenagers and
millennials having this
depression and anxiety and he's like
what the heck you guys
have pretty much everything you want you
live in nice places you have all this
food and why why could you possibly be
depressed
because they don't they don't have a
purpose right and i think you know
andrew yang wants to send everyone
twelve thousand dollars a year it's like
is that i don't know people can just
like sit back and relax and play video
games all day and get a decent
you know apartment and have enough money
just what should we get offensive should
we should we anger all the feminists
are are you prepared to make feminists
angry okay what are we doing here all
right
let's go so i got this uh this is
actually fairly old this is from zach
goldberg he's a great data researcher
and journalist on twitter
and he tweeted this uh uh
he says overall with one exception white
moderates those in the 18 to 29 age
group are more likely to report being
diagnosed with a mental health condition
the differences among white liberals
though are striking
almost half of white liberals in this
cohort
report a diagnosis and in this graph he
shows us
four different age groups 18 to 29 30 to
49 50 64 and 65 plus
65 plus from liberal moderate to
conservative low instances of mental
health
uh i'm sorry mental health conditions
low instances of mental health no no the
opposite we just don't have any
this is amazing among 18 to 29 year old
white liberals
45.9 mental illness white conservatives
20.9 less than half
this is amazing even among the 65 and up
the white liberals are
overwhelmingly more mentally ill
than moderates and conservatives now
we're going to offend the feminists
let's break down white let's well let's
let's let's break down a little bit
these demographics because zach
goldberg gives us another one he says
some of you asked for it so here is the
last chart broken down by
gender the biggest gap with age x
ideological group is between
white liberal men and women in the 18 to
29 category
that's right white liberal women between
the ages of 18 and 29
have a 56.3 percent instance of being
diagnosed with a mental health condition
white liberal men 33.6 among 30 to 49
year olds
white liberals women 39.7 men 29.7
and it's very very similar but even
among white conservative women
27.3 percent in the 18-29
age bracket now the first thing i'll say
is i think the age thing shows us a
generational shift
in mental health diagnosis someone who's
65
probably was not diagnosed with things
diagnosed with conditions when they were
young
and they're older don't care to go to
the doctor and actually get diagnosed
with this
the difference the important factor is
the gap
among white liberals 65 and older it's
almost
identical 15.2 to 15 percent
men white liberal men and women 65 or
older have similar instances of
mental health issues so there is
something creating a
a massive gap between white liberal
gen z millennials and i think
i think i know what it might be what is
it not having families yep
not having relationships not necessarily
families not necessarily kids
but no relationships and i particularly
think no kids
and i wonder if and you give me your
opinion and lydia as well because
you're the ladies in the room we've had
other people on the show say that
the reason women are are unwell and
unhappy and depressed is because they're
not having children
what do you think julie yeah what do you
think not maybe
sorry i hope you don't mind me asking
were you ever like super depressed did
you find this to be an issue for you
before you had your kid
i actually got a lot of anxiety after oh
postpartum anxiety yeah um
oh gosh yeah i think with older people
i think there's was just a stigma
against
reaching out and getting therapy and all
that um with the younger people
i i feel like being a liberal would be
so hard
because if you don't have kids like you
you were talking about you're focused on
all this other stuff
and a lot of stuff is just out of your
control
like the liberals are very focused on
like climate change issues i know that's
a huge one with them having
climate change anxiety and just you know
all this racism and stuff and they're
it's it's out of your control where i
think conservative people are kind of
more focused
in words and on the individual and on
their families where liberals is like i
want to save the world
world peace and it's like no there's
ukrainian
crimea and all this stuff and you can't
do anything on an individual level about
that
that is such a good point because you're
right conservatives do focus on
the individual level and that means they
do things like make families
they have kids they focus on their work
they find things to do that are
meaningful
and they don't tend to stress too much
about stuff that they cannot have
any possible control over like global
warming when it comes to the older
people
a lot of them probably did struggle with
this stuff and they probably just
learned to live with it
or yeah yeah you're don't
suck it up you're right yeah you're
destroying the family
yeah keep it together yeah but then like
the whole family thing i definitely
think that the fact that women aren't
having children is incredibly depressing
to them
i just want to throw my two cents in
there because i think that's probably
one of the biggest problems that we face
you know the meme about you guys ever
watch archer
yeah oh yeah i love the show no i don't
think i was wrong
i'm just not intelligent enough to get a
lot of smart shows
trust me i just played games video games
there was that episode where
um it's been a long time since i've
watched archer i just rewatched it
what's
what's the name of the alana is that her
name uh lana
lana lana archer keeps calling her baby
crazy
yes and it's funny she is but it's like
there's a joke
that very much resonates with i think i
think 30 rock did this
this joke tv shows and culture has have
made jokes about women
whose biological clocks are ticking and
how they want to have kids
men don't experience that i'm wondering
if that
plays a role in why there's a gap
between men and women like a biological
difference
it does for me i'm not in a rush to have
kids and if i was i'd be in a
a completely different person my goals
and my
behavior would be completely that's like
that's dudes yeah
yeah i can have kids when i'm 80. that's
a privilege yeah it's not as easy but
you can
they found that men also lose fertility
i mean
later than women but like 40s and 50s
and there's
more of a chance of having a problem
with the child
it's true i don't want to destroy the
male ego here no i don't know
it it is it is true but the issue is
that women yeah
if a guy's firing off several million
yeah
if 90 of those are just deficient
he's got a couple that are working no
you got like millions
right right so what happens is that
you'll end up seeing you know older guys
have kids
you know and for women it's a lot
different you know i i know it's like
the craziest thing that this is an
offensive topic but it is like feminists
whenever i talk about this kind of stuff
it's like all the feminists aren't
lighting me up on twitter they're all
angry and i'm like
is it is it wrong to point out that
they're they're advising women to freeze
their eggs
i mean do your thing more power to you
it works it really works freezing eggs
i think we're kind of lying to women
saying you know there are
instances of 40 year old women having
birth but they're rare
do you really want to take that risk
probably not if you really want kids
so think about this right we're talking
about mental illness i i don't want to
act like i am saying
this is the sole reason people
experience mental illness
but i'm saying i believe there's a huge
factor in the fact that as a 35 year old
guy with no kids
i should probably start thinking about
having a family but i
got it yeah whatever i'm gonna do term
is okay
but but are you energetic enough for
kids if you're
40 50 60 baby years old because
you saw my son he was jumping up and
down on those feed bags i got energy for
days
oh yeah he's got this yeah i think i'm a
crazy person
but the point is i don't have to
consider
a biological limitation if you were a 35
year old woman you definitely would
so i'm wondering if there are women who
are sitting here and you guys tell me
what you think
when they're looking at the media saying
just freeze your eggs and work and be a
ceo
and they're thinking themselves but i
want to have kids too and you've got
a combination of mainstream liberal
social stigma telling you
no you can't take time off and the
physical realities of
you might have to you could be a ceo
later in life
though like your kids are so young for
such a short
amount of time like i'm 32 i have the
rest of
my life to work i can be 40 50 years old
my mom was a stay-at-home mom she's
still working
so she got it all women you know there's
also the thing that women can have it
all
like no you can't you can't have it all
at the same time
exactly thank you okay yeah i think we
have it backwards and i do think that
you have a point because i've known so
many great and amazing women who went
and they raised their kids
they got them like up into high school
they sent them off and they're like and
then they went back to school a lot of
them became nurses some of them became
teachers and pharmacists and stuff
i was like that seems like such a good
balance because if you want to work
by the time you're that age you'll know
exactly what you want to do your kids
will have a firm start in life and
you'll be able to go
yeah and you can have it like your
career in your head at the same time
you're not worrying about i'm 35 40
years old i might have to get ivf which
is really expensive
right you mentioned your kids are really
young for a short amount of time
reminds me of this really funny story
this guy posted on the internet he was
like 25
and he went and visited his dad or it's
like he was at his parents house for the
holidays
and out of nowhere his dad walks in the
room and just grabs him and lifts him up
as high as he could and he's like dad
what are you doing and his dad said
i saw a meme where it said one day you
care you lifted your child for the last
time and didn't realize it
and then they both started laughing like
his dad was basically like i can pick my
son up whenever i want
but but no that's it's an interesting
point too like the people don't realize
that
you pick your kid up one day the next
day you don't and then that may have
been the last time
you never noticed there's going to be a
last time and so that dad walks in he's
like picking up his 25 year old man of
his son
you know i love it that's cute do you
guys think that there's like resentment
between women
and men the women resenting the men
their age that don't want to have kids
and don't have to
and the women are like but i i feel
guilty for resenting them because they
don't they shouldn't have to
they're not biologically bound so why
would they but then they're
internalizing this resentment
and lashing out against men i think
there's some women who do
but i think there's some men who do you
know what i mean
my bigger concern is not like the
individual it's the it's what we're
encouraging and exacerbating in culture
i would ask that because i think i have
some deep resentment against women that
want to have kids
with me at my age because they they are
on a time clock i'm not and i know they
are and i shouldn't
it's hard to feel the pressure yeah well
i think that's why
you more often see a younger woman an
older man i think it kind of makes sense
the men at a later age are more
financially stable
more mature and they're better able to
raise a child where the younger woman is
both more
fertile okay
so i think that that combination makes
more sense so i would say you know if
you're a young
20 something year old girl probably
don't date guys that are in their young
20s because most of them
you know they don't want to have kids
right now they don't have to
maybe go a decade up or so that's just
my opinion
and now here's here's the the really
offensive part for the feminists the
kind of person who's going to be writing
an article
consistently or writing articles
consistently
is not likely to be you know a
state-home mom who's got
kids and and dealing with them you you
tend to see the careerist feminists
who are in these positions at media
outlets with the time and energy to
write these articles
so their perspective is that of one type
of person
right oh yeah yeah as a stay-at-home mom
you don't really have
as powerful as a voice i would say right
definitely it's really fascinating to
see all these these feminist writers
and and it's no surprise then that many
of the
the women who work in digital media are
feminists because
you know they don't want to have
families they want a career and they
want to fight for that
that's their opinion that's why they're
there or one of the reasons and they're
going to write those opinions over and
over and over again
then it's interesting because i wonder
how that affects other women who know
it's like hey i want to have a kid
before this age
but everything you read from every woman
in a high profile media position is
saying don't have kids freeze your eggs
i was thinking if my mom had focused all
the energy she focused on me and my
brothers
into the world it would have been very
bad for the world because she was
very neurotic not in a harmful way but
neuroticism as a personality trait
uh overly just micromanaging and wanting
everything to be perfect and for me to
not be
exposed to the wrong thing and like if
she had been doing that to other people
i think that would have been devastating
so i could see your point interesting
point i don't know these people are
blogging
as opposed to treating well so you when
i when i look at this chart from zach
goldberg and you can see that
consistently there's a gap between men
and women
except for moderates between 50 and 64
men are more likely to
this is this is fascinating check this
out among white moderates
men are more likely to have been
diagnosed with mental illness by about
one percentage point
you want to know what i think that might
be 50 to 64 years old
divorce no what war veterans boom oh
yeah
vietnam korea maybe yeah
yeah even iraq at this point the first
around
[Music]
way more brutal than we heard about in
the news 20 years ago some of these guys
might have been
30 years old and they might have been a
career have had a career in the military
and now they're getting deployed and
they've so they've seen some stuff
but that's only one group it's only
moderates i mean among liberals it's not
there among conservatives it's still
women
yeah but but i i wonder why is it
and no matter what you say you're gonna
get you're gonna offend somebody that
women consistently report having more
mental health conditions
it's because women are more willing to
go to the doctor
yeah yeah probably or is it because men
are big and strong and and
yeah they don't need nothing going to
get me down depression
punch it out of myself i'll just forget
about it
guy wakes up he's like i'm depressed
today so he punches himself in the face
he's like no i'm not
that's how it works right i'm pretty
sure that would be a mental illness
maybe you should go to the doctor yeah i
think uh you know seeing a therapist
admitting you have a problem is seen as
a weakness
to men i don't want to i don't want to
acknowledge my own
neuroses who does i feel stupid when i
do that and i feel like i'm
creating it when it wasn't there i think
for me it's more
i'm too arrogant not in that i'm like no
one's going to tell me i'm weak it's
it's kind of like no i self-analyze and
i self-uh
diagnose and then i try to assess and
solve any you know things that i see
in myself so when i'm feeling depressed
when i'm anxious when i'm angry
i kind of you know question and think
about it and try and figure out what's
conducive to a positive working
environment or to my goals
and if this thing i'm feeling isn't
doing that then i need to navigate that
myself and i do and it works for me
so you're more self-reliant than a woman
who may
see a benefit in talking to another
person about it talking
yeah or a man yep or maybe self-reliance
yeah yeah yeah
how do you build that trade up uh i
don't know practice
go wander through the woods for a few
days by yourself and like learn how to
survive i guess
did you in the early responsibly when
you were making cell phone youtube
videos in the early days would you just
hyper analyze your behavior no
you never like just poured over your
videos it was like watching yourself and
thinking like oh that i have that trait
i don't like i don't i can't watch it no
it's the comment sections that do that
for me yeah right
tim scherz has listened a whole lot i'm
like i know i've learned a lot about
myself from reading the comment section
yeah you've got a decentralized network
of people talking about what you're
doing wrong
it's like it's great it's so great you
know when when they're in good faith but
even when they're not
it's funny because there's a lot of
people who will claim i
claim i say something too much not
realizing that there's like a period
where for like a few days i'll say one
thing too much
and then it goes away that does happen
to people you go through phases of like
sayings and stuff or even like the way
we talk
like accents sometimes you'll your
posture probably for a few days will be
a certain way
yes we all straighten that's interesting
yeah there was a period where i would
say at the end of the day
like 10 times in a video yeah and then
people are like dude you say at the end
of the day all the time i'm like yeah
it's a good point i should stop saying
that
and then there was like a then like when
i was trying to correct it i'd be
recording and i'd be like look anyway at
the end of the day
then i'd stop and i'd be like okay
self-correcting
so anyway and then i'd go and i'd chop
it out oh nice
do a clever edit so you can't see it i
got a question so do you think this is
why the apa thinks that
masculinity is toxic or whatever because
guys don't go to therapists because they
do things like self-analyze and tend to
be stoic and they don't really want to
talk about their feelings
do you think probably what's apa stand
for american psychological association
i think the the reality is that there
are some men
who are just weak pathetic
they can't handle the realities and
there's some strong men who just don't
need to be told what's wrong with them
i'm kidding uh but in all seriousness
there are some guys that are
stoic and calm and pragmatic and
rational
and there are some guys who do need help
who feel like they can't do it because
they have to emulate these other kind of
guys you know what i mean
so for me like i said i don't i don't
think there's any kind of
sitting down and talking to someone
about my feelings it's ever going to
help me in any way
it would absolutely waste my time and
i'll be frustrated and angered
by it if i have an issue and i'm feeling
some way i have to
like navigate in my brain and like draw
it out
figure out what it is what's what's
what's what's bothering me
okay now we can move forward here's our
plan sitting down and talking with
someone would be like i'd be looking i'm
going you're going too slow for me i
need to solve this problem in five
minutes
not an hour this doesn't work but there
are a lot of people that do need that
person
and they're scared to talk about it
because they want to be seen as tough
they don't want to be seen as weak
they need to do it people need to
realize about the individual man it's
about you you need what you need
so i'll tell you this the one thing you
should always do is don't care what
other people think about you
people are like you went to the doctor
it's like i did i felt like i needed it
then you should do it
you should absolutely do it so you know
one of my favorite quotes from marcus
aurelius is that even a soldier needs
the help of his fellow soldiers and i
was thinking
that to me speaks about the psychology
of men even back in the roman empire
like this is something that he knew that
people needed to hear especially guys
like you have to put it in a way that
guys understand and sympathize with i
definitely feel like
for me personally when i hear the
narrative of guys
being like too too macho and not wanting
to the doctor
it really feels like a woman's
perspective right absolutely i don't
hear it from guys
i don't i i swear to god in my life i
have seen a guy cry a handful of times
uh i've talked to my friends and i've
i've rarely if ever had a guy be like
i need help and like crying about their
depression but i have had guys who've
done that
i have i have seen people who have lost
loved ones who have lost you know their
dog or whatever
and it's devastating and they're in pain
and they want to talk about it or they
want to be alone and just work to their
feelings
but i definitely feel like for me
personally
whenever i hear this narrative you know
oh so many men are hurting and they're
too too scared because they have to be
macho i'm like i just think that women
are more emotional
more emotional than guys and that's okay
yeah that's totally fine
that's yeah it's putting that i i guess
if you're talking
to the ascent to the to the uh
constructivists though
yeah this whole conversation is bannable
that's right because they believe
everything's blank slate you know
it's like they say there's no difference
between men and women
and then they do the transsexual thing
it's like they're i
i just don't get it it seems like
this should be a good point so you're
admitting that you're a bigot
i'm just saying like they're saying it
seems like they're saying there's no
difference between men and women women
are not more emotional than men and then
they say there's a transsexual thing
where you can switch genders because
genders are different and it's like
well so so this is this is an
interesting thing you need to understand
there's actually two generations of
thought in
the trans community there's the binary
trends and the non-binary trans
so there have been some very prominent
trans women canceled
you know attacked and harassed by the
gen z trans
gender individuals because in their
ideology it's gender non-binary gender
spectrum
so it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're transitioning from
male you know man to woman you're
literally just moving between this
this spectrum so some people are gender
fluid which means they can trans
back and forth depending on the time of
the day yeah and there's a bunch of
other uh genders
where they say it fits at some point on
a scale of one to a thousand you know
i'm a
327 leaning you know male or whatever
but for the older generation it tends to
be more binary trans
so uh some of the you know some of the
friends that i have were were definitely
in the more in the category of
more binary they gen they genuinely
believed
they were only two genders only two
biological sexes etc
now when those people go online and post
these things they get attacked and
harassed by the younger generation that
believes
it's a spectrum i think i think one of
the interesting
ways to describe the difference in the
ideologies is
the the common uh uh the colloquial
terminology
assigned male at birth or assigned
female at birth
so you're that's this it's it's a it's a
in my opinion a strange way of looking
at it and it fits into this idea that
male and female
don't exist when in fact they do male
and female literally exist
you don't look at the giraffe and then
say we don't know if it if it's male or
female because it hasn't told us
you literally just say well you know we
looked at it and we can see it's they're
they're they're wrongs
yeah it comes down to like this argument
about the nuance between
understanding and and and how you
quantify things
and it's not always easy to create a
criteria for quantification
um but tip the typical understanding
male and female is a reference to
the what are they called gametes is that
the right word yeah the sex cells the
sex cells that they produce
and then whenever you say that you'll
get you know one of these left
individuals saying so a person who can't
produce them anymore is no longer and
you're like
exceptions yeah true yeah
it's just but it's such a little but
anyway long story short it's not a unif
there's no unified ideology in gender
ideology and so what happens then is
like twitter's rule set youtube's rule
set
doesn't fit either one it goes for both
creating this fractured all-encompassing
and broken
contradictory rule set in many regards
very confusing humans are animals
we always got to remember that we're
part of the animal kingdom always have
been always
will be um and unless we evolve to a
different species but the
homo sapien is an animal and when we're
born we have sex organs
now you can always reidentify gender and
what that means and
i think they're like you're saying the
terms of service are trying to to
acknowledge both like you can still kind
of have the biological argument
but they're trying to placate or make
that's what people don't get hurt
i'm sorry i guess aren't trampled on or
that people have the right to
artistically express their gender
beliefs and things like that i have a i
have a i have a red line
in this you know i mean it's like civil
rights for everybody
people should be allowed to uh defend
themselves to live be happy to be free
from violence
if we're all paying taxes then we should
be allowed to share in
you know the bounty of whatever those
taxes are supposed to be paying for even
blowing up kids right which is the bad
part of it but hey that's reality and
that's kind of stuff we don't want to
happen
the long story short is i would love for
you know my my transgendered married
friends to be armed to the teeth
and buying their drugs with bitcoin and
be free from oppression from the
government because they want to be in
private on their farm you know what i
mean very
pro-liberty protect the people let them
protect themselves and let them do their
thing
uh i i guess for me i have a hard line
on this idea that male and female don't
exist
like that's clearly just not true and
it's becoming this weird anti-science
movement
where i turn on the tv and they say
outright ma like the
assigned male at birth like you weren't
assigned it
you are you are like you know it's like
red maybe they could say identified
male at birth maybe it would make more
sense because then i guess what they're
trying to say is that
there are some people who are intersex
and so if they're born and they appear
to be male a doctor could say you are
when you're not and then i guess
identified by doctor as would make more
sense
why are we changing the complete
language because of this small minority
of people like it doesn't make
sense it could be that it's
it's an evolution of our species and now
we're in the we're in the early
ages of multi-sex um organisms
that are evolving the issue is
authoritarianism that's the only issue i
have if you try to force people to do
things
but there's a there's a range uh the
statistics show it's between like
you know point i think it's like point
six percent to like one point three
percent of people that are
non uh uh they don't fall perfectly into
x or x y
yeah and if we're then going to try and
navigate how we respect
a you know 1.3 on the high end or even
you know 0.6
i still a lot of people and i have no
problem being like hey man you know let
me know
what makes you comfortable i'm here to
to to work with you and things like that
the problem is the authoritarianism so
like if someone comes to me
and just says by the way you know this
is how i prefer to be addressed i just
be like okay you know whatever
if the government comes out and says you
must or else i'd be like
i don't know about that one it is really
weird though there's this case going on
right now where a teacher refused to
refer to a trans student by
um i think miss or i'm not sure maybe it
was mister
uh and then he referred to the student
who was you know
assigned female at birth as the
nomenclature says
and got sue got in trouble got
threatened and then he filed a lawsuit
saying it was free speech
i just find it interesting right if a
teacher was like i'm not going to call
you what you want to be called
you know what i mean like when
regardless of whether it's a pronoun
what if the teacher was like hey dingus
it's like my name's bill i don't care
dingus
i can call you whatever i want right you
know what i mean so it's kind of like
not even necessarily humiliation but
disrespectful i get the idea that people
are like i believe
in using language this way and forcing
someone to change how they speak
because pronouns aren't someone's name
pronouns are a function of language not
an individual
i just think there's also an interesting
argument be like what if a teacher is
calling you an insult
would we would we be like don't call
them what if what if he called you not
even an insult and just called you like
the wrong name over and over again yeah
and didn't care
acknowledging and then you kept
complaining like that's not my name you
know
i wish the teacher would get my name
right they'll probably be reprimanded by
the school i would imagine that's a good
point
um all right we're going to read this
article because we
had this pulled up before and uh i'm
going to tell everybody right now before
we read this article
yeah i'll tell you the one thing
everybody we hear the most of
from guests and in conversations
not everybody says this and it's a small
minority people do
but we've had people come in and say i'm
more than happy to do the show so long
as you don't ever ask me questions about
transgenderism
or trans people and i'd be like i mean
if there's news there's news if there's
not there's not and i got to tell you
it's it's if someone comes on the show
and they're like i won't talk about this
and there's no point in asking because
they'll just not interact with you and
it'll be a really weird
conversation where you're like so what
do you think and they just don't say
anything so it's like
all right i guess and the reason for it
is
almost no matter what you do you get
attacked when you bring the stuff up
well i don't know what else to do but
yeah talk about it we have the story for
new york post
cnn ridiculed for saying there is no
consensus for assigning sex at birth the
new york post reports
cnn is being ridiculed online for
insisting there is no consensus criteria
for assigning sex at birth
with critics telling the network to look
just below the waist for insight
the left-leaning network statement was
quickly shared online after appeared in
a news story wednesday about south
dakota banning transgender athletes from
women's sports
it's not possible to know a person's
gender identity at birth and there is no
consensus criteria for assigning sex at
birth
cnn's devin cole wrote critics quickly
ripped the outlet for reporting in a
straight fact
rather than attributing it to others and
noting differing views
quote i've gotten used to a lot of woke
craziness never thought i'd see
biological sex in scare quotes a twitter
user
wrote cnn isn't a news organization they
are straight up
activists online media critic lee
zabatka
wrote while conservative commentator ben
shapiro said only an idiot would believe
the network's claim
others suggested a simple solution i'm
not a doctor cnn but if you look just
below the waist you may get some insight
and then they just they're just quoting
a bunch of twitter users you're ragging
on cnn but cnn literally did this
when did this come out when did cnn do
that a couple a couple days ago last
week
yeah i mean the stories from yesterday
and we were thinking about talking about
it but a lot of people don't
you know want to bring it out it's a hot
potato that's dumb
it's dumb yeah can i talk about it no
biological sex is real
it is real it's how we make more people
yeah
it's you either got that or this what i
think one problem with this well hold on
hold on to be fair
or intersex right right so it's it's so
that that's that that's the issue at
hand is that
you you do have a lot of people who are
like it's either that or this
then you have people like dr deborah so
for instance who's
very intelligent saying well you know
it's bimodal
there is an overlap but for the most
part it's overwhelmingly
you know male or female if you want to
have like an honest nuanced conversation
it's really difficult to have in
hyper-polarized times but i'm sorry like
i have a line
right biological sex is real to say
there's no consensus criteria for
assigning sex at birth
i don't like the phrase assigning it
that's very activisty they identify you
as the doctor season says this is what
the baby is
and they can be wrong and they have been
wrong there's some prominent activists
who were incorrectly identified because
they were intersex
like there's one woman who is actually
biologically male
based on dna and the issue was i i
forgot what's
what the syndrome is called but did not
develop like the
the testes did not produce testosterone
so now they very much
this individual looks very much female
even though genetically is male
and so then when you have a doctor say
that and they realize that's not true it
doesn't fit how they feel
and they actually want to be a man like
yeah that makes sense these people are
real they exist
you know making sure we protect the
rights of all people is
part of the conversation but when you
get activists coming out and saying
actually there's no biological
sex it's like okay what i got from this
is there is this writer
said there's difficult or challenging to
establish gender identity at birth and
then immediately in the next sentence
said biological sex or and as if they
were the same thing
no gender identity and biological sex
are different
yeah yep and they used to make that
argument that used to be their strongest
case they were like
gender isn't sex sex isn't gender who
would ever
that's what i learned in my college yeah
sociology classes
and now it seems like it's flipped where
it's like there's interchangeable
yeah i think that's due to the media i
think it's due to a bunch of really dumb
people who work in media who don't
understand things who write about things
and conflated them and made the mistake
for real so what happens is you'll get
some like intellectual saying
well biological sex does exist gender is
the social
constructs that have formed around the
biological sexes
and thus people could identify between
any of
you know and any in between or outside
of gender
in fact if it is a simple social
construct then
certainly someone could make up their
own social construct and that's an
intellectual argument
and then someone who works for like the
new york times are having the post goes
biological sex ain't real because they
didn't understand the actual argument
being presented
over time it morphs into you're not male
so this is another issue i take when
they say someone is like they're uh
you know a transgender person
transitioned to male or female i'm like
no no
no between man or woman that was i
thought it was trans woman not trans
male i thought that was offensive to say
but it's really hard to keep up with
there's another reason why a lot of
people just refuse to talk about this
stuff
because what you say today could be
offensive next week it could be the
right thing to say today
offensive next week case in point wmixon
you got you know about wim mixon
wymixon have you heard that no it's
women within
oh yeah okay i didn't i've never heard
it pronounced yes who knows
so it's in wimexin uh
the x is supposed to symbolize the
symbol for trans
and so they change the o to an x it
might work in written language but in
spoken language it's confusing and
people are like
i didn't know what you're doing right
exactly i've seen it on twitter but yeah
yeah it's a very very online thing
regular people probably don't understand
well
when that word was made it was
appropriate and then for some reason a
month later became offensive
you know a couple months later some
organization used the word and got
attacked
how dare you use that word trans women
are women so you don't need to say
wimxing
then a year later they started using wim
xen again so it's like
no matter what you do someone will claim
someone will say it's wrong it's like
it's like i mentioned before the liberal
a circular firing squad or mexican
standoff where they're all staring at
each other waiting for anything they can
use as an infraction
so people don't want to talk about this
importantly i think don't don't ridicule
it
and and not publicly if you're going to
talk about it do not ridicule this don't
be
mean to people yeah it's easy as it is
to be like well that seems stupid to me
so
let's make a joke don't do it it's not
stupid to everybody and it won't be in
the future it'll probably be more
important to other people he's just
you know you know what bothers me about
a lot of conservatives is
their desire to be mean like i'm
smarter and better and you're dumb so
i'm not saying every single one of them
but i see it i see it a lot and i'm like
i don't like that
you know i don't like someone who's like
they would approach a story like this by
laughing and ridiculing and being mean
and i'm like dude but you don't win
arguments by doing that you know a good
example is
when milo yiannopoulos fat shamed a guy
to jim
oh yeah and i was like i asked him i was
like why would you do that he was like
it works and i'm like
it already worked the guy's in the gym
now you're gonna scare them off the gym
what are you doing man you know
like uh uh i understand there are people
who believe fat shaming works because it
makes me want to lose weight and get
active
but the guy in the gym you won yeah he's
doing it
he's like he's fighting that's the kind
of
beyond not nice it's ineffective like
what's your real goal
someone actually was saying that we were
talking about
something about mental illness and uh
how we were being like kind of kind and
like
you know people need help people need
help in society but that i
had been too hard on people that are
obese and that i'm i'm treating it like
it's not a mental illness and i think
they might be right because i've been
you know i'm a huge foodie and into
sugar and
make the best of it make the best
wow and i'm like obesity is a pro
obesity is a problem
and i and i do believe obviously this
problem but i do not want to
ostracize people that are have that
problem
this is this is a guy ladies and
gentlemen who complains about the sugar
industry and then makes the best bread i
know
a little bit of sugar goes a long way
people people people yeah it's like a
fresh bread and they cut a slice of it
and people are like
impressed every time and then you go and
complain but the sugar's bad and you're
the one giving it to you two teaspoons
of uh white granulated sugar for five
cups of flour
four and a half clips is that your
secret technique it was actually from
paula deen
i'll give you the skinny that recipe is
a paladin wait was she was she the
racist one
yes paula deen pizza dough that recipe
so so you're a hypocrite and a racist
apparently i support a racist i didn't
even know
i wanted to ask you have you ever
watched my 600 pound life no
i did and i was really struck by the
fact that i didn't watch it like as a
show i've seen the commercials no it's
okay i watched 98 fiance it's okay
so i actually i watched some of it for a
speech that i wrote and i was like it's
never about
food it's always about something else
these people are abused
they're being enabled they've been
manipulated they're being like
their parents will go out and bring them
to stuff because they can no longer
leave their house
and it's like it's not about food the
food is filling a gap and we're lucky
in america we can use it we don't use
alcohol like russians do
always a coping mechanism you know yeah
it is scoping mechanism food i can see
that
you were talking about uh conservatives
just being mean
not well i wanna clarify too i'm gonna
clarify real quick yeah there are some
conservatives
that like being mean yeah they want to
trigger the libs and
do dumb stuff well i think a lot of
conservatives complain about virtue
virtue signaling which is true i mean
some stuff you just kind of have to roll
your eyes at people like i'm such a
great person blah blah blah
but i think on the right there's also
vice signaling
i've seen it a lot over this covet thing
where people take selfies with them in
the grocery store without a mask and
it's like
look at me it's the opposite of virtue
signaling it's the same thing
it's it is still virtual signaling
though it's just for their side
yeah i call it vice signaling because
it's yeah it's it's the same thing look
at how bad i i can be
yeah no no but yeah it
it it's effectively the same thing i
understand your point though by
signaling like
when somebody goes on twitter and just
insults and berates
somebody because the right is piling on
so i just i'm absolutely not a fan of
that stuff
yeah like the whole like um meghan
markle thing like i looked at this i had
no opinion about it but i saw a bunch of
conservatives attacking her and i'm just
like
did you care about this yesterday like i
didn't
i don't know yeah and it's just they
just want to be like
rude i guess i i got hit up by fox
they wanted to have me on so a lot of
people saw me on fox talking about big
tech and social media there were some
other instances
where i've recently been on fox as well
not on the tv on like radio and other
segments
and around the time of the meghan markle
thing and so i get an email from a
producer and they're like can you talk
about this and i was like i don't know
anything about the royal family
and they're like oh okay it was you know
it's big enough to have
i was just like i purposefully avoid
nonsense
like the royal family does not have any
like it's celebrity gossip for americans
yeah we fought awards and i have to
worry about the royal family i wonder
how frequently they hit up people and
they're like uh the answer is always yes
if i'm asked to go on tv because it's
good for my career even if i know
nothing about it so you get a lot of
these people just
feigning you know knowledge at least you
had the
fortitude to acknowledge you didn't you
weren't worth
their time yeah i've seen the
opportunity for your own selfish game
for for you know some advice i guess to
say you know there are a lot of people
who absolutely are like oh man i can go
on tv tell me what to say
i never do that i'm like i don't have
anything to say about the royal family
i'm not interested
like i've been invited on a bunch of big
podcasts i say no oh my
what am i gonna talk about you give me
something i can talk about maybe i'll do
it
otherwise i don't know whatever i think
if people
just focus on themselves and what they
want to do and stay true to themselves
is their better path forward but uh
going back to the thing about
conservatives we know that there are a
lot of leftists who are virtue signalers
who will mock and grift and berate
people on the right
or just not the left and lie about them
in order to earn points
i think a really good example is this
show exactly i had a big argument with
this with his friend of mine
and what had happened was i made a post
about the chauvin trial like here's what
happened this is crazy this is huge for
the defense the defense basically said
george floyd had odd before and had
similar symptoms at the time of his
arrest here
and we learned that according to his
girlfriend the dude with floyd was
their dealer so i'm like this is huge
for the defense
because a third-degree murder in
minneapolis is if you provide a
substance to someone that kills them
that's your fault so that's this other
guy's fault
which could present very serious
reasonable doubt as to what happened
with floyd and who was responsible
and so you know someone comes in and
they say oh here comes tim pool's
confirmation bias and
all of his you know cult followers don't
want to read the actual news
and i had a conversation with this
person i was like you need to understand
what happened here
you don't watch my show you don't know
the opinions expressed on
on this show you don't know the opinions
of the people who comment on the show
and you look at it and immediately
assume if we are saying the defense
got a victory you know in today's
hearing
you assume it's a bunch of trump
supporting red hat wearing maga
flag waving people when in fact it's a
variety of people who are just paying
attention
you come in acting like you know
everything and everyone starts trying to
explain to you calmly and you get angry
this is what happens for a lot of people
they walk into a room where people are
saying wow the defense in the chauvin
trial this is big i mean it's not
perfect
and then also they're like what is this
a bunch of maga conservatives
you guys are all biased and then when
people try saying listen listen
here's the guy who was the dealer here's
what the judge said about the guy
about floyd putting the tablet in his
mouth and look i don't know what you're
talking about i i've
watched rachel maddow so i know
everything instead of having that
rational conversation they get mad and
assert that they're right and you're
wrong
it's a really amazing you know thing i
think it's it's definitely a vice
when people assume it's not me who's
wrong it's
everyone else it's like yo if everywhere
you go you smell crap
take a look at your boot well yeah
that's my
how do you stay friends with people like
like that is that more of just like
forcing yourself to stay social do you
feel like
loyalty to them because you've known him
for a long time um
i treat everybody with a certain level
of respect if there's someone i've done
for a long time
you know i'm not going to treat a person
better because i know them you know what
i mean
i try to be fair for someone i don't
know
i suppose if like there were two people
hanging on the side of a cliff and i
knew one of them
like i'm gonna save that person over the
person i don't know
i guess it depends though i mean these
are tough questions right like let me
ask you ian you see you're
you're standing there and there's a cl
as a cliff
and you've got your mom hanging but then
you've got a seven-year-old
girl hanging on the other side which who
would you save my god
what kind of stuff question right the
personal desire to save your mother or
the potential the potential of the child
she would want me to save the kid
yeah probably that's a good point so i
would
well there you go it's not an easy
question for everybody yeah these are
tough questions
it's like in spider-man you know in the
movie when he had mary jane
and the school bus full of kids he saved
them both because she spied
that was my initial thought so
use your web shooters to save both of
the same time
okay and we're good got it yeah
i don't know not easy questions man how
about we go to super chats if you have
not already my friends
smash that like button and become a
member over at timcast.com because
um looks like we're not going to have
the website up but this is
this is okay there's actually a really
obvious reason for it that i didn't
consider
and yet that reason is what's that why
the website will not be be launched
as of today beta testing what's today
april 2nd no no what's today uh friday
oh yeah yeah it's friday weekend it's
friday yeah
which friday oh it's good friday it's a
good friday it is a lot of people
they were like you know look it's good
friday easter sunday okay
so it's a four-day weekend and i was
like oh okay okay okay okay like i'm not
gonna tell anybody to work on good
friday and through the weekend for
easter it's like i get it man
so uh but anyway go to teamgas.com
because i think early next week
hopefully um but but regardless of the
format of the website we are preparing
shows and and we want to get started on
the stuff you know ian was talking about
some developers and doing this open
source technology
and just kind of going crazy and
building out technology and tools that
are gonna make the world a better place
but also making good
content we're gonna do a lot man we're
we're uh
slowly seeding everything we need we've
got some people joining really soon to
start uh producing more content and it's
a common
so make sure you sign up and don't
forget to like the video if you haven't
already subscribe hit the notification
bell and
share this show if you really do like it
all right let's see we got a ton of
super chats
um as always it seems like youtube has
made it so i can't read the name of the
first super chat so
can't read it it says suggestion imagine
nerdy version of jordan peterson that
analyzes cartoons anime games
and tries to teach important life
lessons like that incredible editing to
make it as epic and entertaining as
possible
timmy you have to check out the channel
the meaning of nerd oh well there you go
snowboard dan oh this must be a mistake
he says happy birthday
ian thank you dan it is ian's birthday
it ladies and gentlemen it is
according to 42 years old on
4-2 which i didn't see coming until
yesterday very cool and they said it's
the meaning of life
and uh that one that one book it'd be
funny if like after the choice after the
show ends we like go downstairs and
often ian starts floating and a beam of
light like comes around him and his eyes
are glowing
it is going to happen and then he just
starts like firing gigantic lightning
bolts and blowing everything up and
people are running and screaming and
it's
promising i feel like it's i'm wrapping
the first uh
trimester of my life right now that i'll
go to like 150 or 120 with all this life
extension stuff and a lot of it's going
to be like it's going to be a different
version of life like an outer spa like a
different hopefully
weird you are a trip man
[Laughter]
you just found this out the audience is
live
yeah uh someone just challenged me to a
fight oh
jayvon cronin says the only thing i have
ever disagreed with tim about is how you
say mcdonald's
like wtf is mcdonald's tim
you don't know who mcdonald's is i guess
if you grow up in in the city
we jokingly call it mcdonald's it's like
meant to be a silly way to say
mcdonald's not sheriff really
adults huh interesting yeah
yeah yeah of course you know it's a it's
a it's a silly way to be like mcdonald's
instead of mcdonald's
good ol what is it scottish food yeah oh
yeah sure
oh let's see here let's trey allen says
i'm glad
your puritan capitalistic nature could
not let you take today off and we're all
thank
thankful tim and team yes it's good
friday
but uh i'm not uh good friday
specifically catholic
christians it's christian christian yeah
yeah and it's the day before jesus rose
from the dead no it's a day where he
died
oh jesus and then sunday is where they
said friday so they crucified him on
like wednesday and they let him hang
there for two days
and then he died is that what it is dude
stabbed him yeah geez
he's suffocated to death on the cross is
the gold gotham real
the what the gol gotham uh yeah the hill
gold gotham no that's golgotha
the gold gotham what is it what's from
dogma
where uh uh uh what's it asriel summons
the the demon made of human feces no
that would be a no
okay bible sorry i heard my last name
crossland
is from crossland hills in england i
haven't confirmed but i think it's where
they used to crucify people
interesting yeah you should go there
yeah find out the truth
the cross all right let's see oblivion
says iowa governor reynolds signed
constitutional carry into law today
took too long but it's nice to have a
right restored for a change repeal the
nfa
wow always amazing to hear about
constitutional carry that is an amazing
thing
what state iowa cool that's great
remind me to visit iowa walk around with
a barrett m82
carrying it getting really tired because
it's a heavy thing to carry yeah
and people are going to laugh and be
like i get you're trying to make a point
but come on
anyone can do that it's a grenade
launcher right no no it's an
anti-material rifle
50 bmg yeah so you know taking out
helicopters and tanks and buildings you
know what i mean
when you need to terry matt burkhart
says hey tim would you consider having
jonathan witch uh whichman on your show
he's from wisconsin running for governor
in 2022 great candidate center right he
doesn't really have the resources to
become a mainstream candidate
um perhaps we don't like to take
suggestions
because people then turn the super chat
into a suggestion machine but
you know we'll always look into people
teddy mason teddy mason all right taking
time off from talking to jerry says
happy birthday ian tim love what you do
it's extremely important to promote
people to think
critically but i'll catch the podcast in
the morning gotta get back to the jam
night on acas hey there you go all right
thank you ransom puppy says hey tim just
wanted to ask you if you've heard about
the band
uh anal nathrak their latest
uh music video and darkment seem to be
very anti-establishment
i highly recommend checking it out if
you're into death metal
not really i like their use of like not
a big death metal person i don't know
what to say
creative sam ray oh this is this is this
is a racist he says asians make far
better stuff
japan with nissan toyota honda sony
seiko plus tokyo is super clean
and wish the general american public can
learn more from their culture tim do you
have a watch collection
seiko i do not have a watch connection
watch collection
i will say tokyo is awesome
man it's it's a it's a really different
culture i'll tell you that
you know there's a little there's a
there's a bunch of i'll try to be family
friendly
there are a bunch of businesses for men
to
relieve themselves in adult manners oh
okay they're literal like
i i saw this sign everywhere when i was
in tokyo
and i was like what is this you know i
was like i didn't know what it was and
then the
my my fixer which is you know local
japanese woman she was like oh it's you
know and then she explained to me that
guys you know every so often they've got
urges and needs and they go in there and
there's like used underwear and jars and
like you know boxes you could buy
it's a different place with advancements
in artificial intelligence and robotics
they're aiding thanks for the
recommendation
yeah yeah they are super yeah
robotically it's very different
they have their own set of problems all
right let's see we got too many super
chats today too many guys
conti says tim us uh u.s military just
had extremist stand down training today
even though they talk about antifa b11
supremacy extreme
our extremists they only show videos
from c-span from january 6 and some
shootings that was done by
white people weird
julian powell says can you believe
please stop commenting on the thoughts
of the black community
none of you are black and most of your
comments just come from stereotypes and
inference
none of you are black so you couldn't
comprehend black life well that's
exactly my opinion that's why when we
had a comment from a nigerian immigrant
i said i'd defer to you i wouldn't know
i think there are a lot of people who
do think they know on the right and the
left and try and tell other communities
what it's like it's the weirdest thing
and it's a perfect example of one of the
reasons i don't like what my serious
problems with the critical race
theorists
is when i get some like uppity white
progressive being like let me explain to
you what it's like to be a
marginalized person and i'm like no no
no no you we don't do that here
no you don't come to me and bring that
to me sorry
but uh respect julian absolutely brother
francis says hi guys wanted to apply to
work for you guys would be my dream
career
i've sent some emails hope you guys can
see them also wanted to contribute to
btc monthly how can we set that up it's
very difficult to do and we haven't set
it up but
brother francis we will search for that
email
rosa brand says what used to be
entertainment with books and movies even
video games has turned into larping
that's what i saw in the last last
year's riots kids running amok are
peeing
that's right doctordoctor says
it's all play money shots on me tonight
while it's worth anything
i can make this back in experiences and
hardships all in the process of making
friends and family
as always thank you guys for doing you
and ian thanks for being the voice of
unreason when there's too much
there's too much of making sense gotta
shake it okay
uh pete diesel has a comment for you
ewan he says infantry comes from the
french word
infonteria meaning foot soldiers too
experienced too inexperienced for
cavalry
oh so there is perhaps a relation
between infant
and experience i should go into the
roman the latin of that as well
i'm curious arceon says here to promote
my channel
arceon i taught catholicism politics and
more hey there you go very cool
trent lamolino says hey gang love what
is on the horizon but make it a
mandatory daily obligation to get adam
curry and no agenda is vital
stay safe john uh am i familiar
i don't know adam curry was like the
founder of podcasts i think oh
interesting that's fun
john r says eating locally sourced honey
will help with pollen allergies
i've heard that interesting we went we
were surrounded by farms
and we went to a farm and got a bunch of
farm fresh meat it
is amazing i gotta tell you man
if you've had that store-bought bacon
you ain't had bacon until you have real
bacon from a farm
fresh it's legit put it on the grill and
it's just like wow
real food is always so much better
character holding says think it was hook
worms they secrete an enzyme that
pacifies the immune system
they live in your intestines clears up
allergies oh maybe that what it was
that's what it was
this is amazing ian you were right
neyrad agava says ian is right
infantry comes from the latin root word
in fonz meaning infancy
it shows up later in the 1500s as
infante meaning foot soldiers too low in
rank too young or too poor
to be cavalry very cool well how about
that
and we still use it it's a different
system now because those people could be
cavalry but they're put into the
infantry so maybe it's not about wiping
their brain but that's the
and aoc wasn't wrong about the relation
between surge and insurgent
oh yeah anymore uh surge meaning is the
the root word is to to like a sudden
flow
uh and then insurgent was to
sudden flow from the inside yes well so
it was just like flow from within the
original word surge was just like
the way we described surge it's the same
meaning and then insurgent was a
reference to like
the action the action of surging through
yeah so it became a reference to the
people and
the insurgents so there's a similar
route there baxter says tim
strauss howe is for people not well read
in history he references world war
ii civil war and revolutionary war but
conveniently skips over world war one
napoleonic wars etc
there's always the case with these books
strass house just the latest meme people
in dc are gushing over
because it's fun to think the world
isn't so boring and we can predict the
future
but you're right it's probably true
low and light says tim please have
someone on
that was there at the capitol on january
6th uh let's see
uh you would then stop flipping calling
calling dc a riot or a siege
that is offensive and bs well i've seen
videos of people at the front gate
bashing the windows and then people
fighting them
i've seen the videos of the people
running in and clashing with the police
and i've seen the video having the door
open
i think there are people who are there
who
uh only like walked around and didn't
realize
what was going on at the capitol and
think it was only the peaceful side
but we quite literally had uh i believe
we had more than one of the journalists
we did we had two yeah
who were down there telling us
everything that was happening yeah like
yeah richie was on like right after
yeah the next day richard jorge i think
sideways says i'm 26 and single so
instead of kids i get stressed out
by building up and restoring modeling
resto modeling old cars the issue may be
a lack of hobbies
cars are my kids or cats cats
don't recommend cats everyone get cats
mastermind says ian's words about crimea
inspired me to do my first super chat
oh that's an epic dude very cool crimea
stuff's crazy man
about it the whole night russia was
amassing troops you were talking about
this earlier yeah
the ukrainians just issued a draft on
the april 1st
16 000 or so ukrainians are now drafted
um
they want to liberate from what i've
heard they want to liberate crimea
russia's like nope we're going to send
tanks if you invade us because russia
thinks crimea is russian
ukraine thinks crimea is ukrainian wow
it's a messy situation man
corey hill says love the show tim please
consider the legendary mark kern aka
grums as a guest for your show
he is a leader in pushing back against
the insanity and the culture worn as a
brilliant game developer
and from for those that don't know if
you've played world of warcraft i
believe there's a ring called the mark
of kern or it may not be a ring maybe
just a
an item this is named after mark kern
one of the og developers of world of
warcraft
and marcus rad and i would love to have
him on the show i think i
i i've dealt with him in the past
periodically um
we should definitely reach out to him
and have him on the show because he's a
cool dude
he's working on a new video a new video
game too and we can talk about that oh
very cool
yeah look him up
razor tune says five months ago i
released my first game i was hoping to
bring some humor during the lockdown
it never took off now and it may be too
late maybe you could give it a shout out
check out what is it corona run on steam
2d platformer
interesting it's never too late yeah
it's never too late maybe you know
people will find a fun game marcus
carter says i'm a 37 year old disabled
combat veteran with a three-year-old
child on life support since birth
i just started a pack shorting dc
because despite my problems they are
nothing
to the problems we all face together if
we don't recapture our government
visit shortingdc.org for more hey good
luck marcus and thank you for your super
chat yeah
michael schwabel says old quote you
don't become an adult until you have
people that you are responsible for
definitely golin's thought says i will
send my kid to school i can teach my kid
many things but i cannot teach them
social interaction
they need to learn to deal with all
kinds of people especially how to deal
with jerks and difficult people
yes uh okay rob brown says i love this
chick
there you go
[Laughter]
bonnie bailey says hugs ian try to keep
it together you look so sad
i feel you guys try to stay strong hugs
thanks i think the war stuff got you
down you were like really serious or
you're like
the war's starting china's gonna take
taiwan you got me scared
over here
it's crazy man yeah you before the show
you were talking about this and
it's like a really scary thought if
russia
makes a move on ukraine because a
ceasefire is over and other amassing
troops
the us will absolutely prioritize
ukraine and then china will immediately
seize taiwan and they'll
they'll point at russia and say hey
they're doing it and then all the
countries around the world that have a
place they want to invade we'll start
we'll invade it they'll be like america
can't stop us all and then the russians
and the chinese won't fight each other
at first
just like the nazis and the russians
didn't fight each other at first until
germany invaded russia
china's this imperialist monster has
been messing with russia
may eventually invade russia and then
the russians will flip
hopefully it doesn't happen hopefully it
doesn't yeah
all right let's see uh zueva bro
julie it's chris tell alex i said hi
otherwise i love the show tim
who's chris you don't know someone you
don't know anybody named chris i do but
i know a lot of them juliet's chris tell
alex i said hi oh hi chris
you're going to get a text later and
they're going to go oh yeah like
there's like a million of you
normies get out says mandatory military
service for two years would solve this
problem
service guarantees citizenship would you
like to know more
i would like to know more i'm not
convinced it would though i think it
would make a bunch of rebels
if if the government instated the draft
as a mandatory requirement
you would end up with a wave of
insurgents like this is america man you
got to realize
doesn't matter if you're left or right
there people are going to be like
government can't tell me what to do
people got guns too the draft i think
the vietnam draft like for the most part
worked
like most people were like okay i guess
but a lot of people were like no
a lot of people died dude like in
vietnam yeah yeah
they were drafted yeah right a lot of
people just said okay and went along
with it
but they didn't want to go they didn't
want to go to jail either
exactly the draft is pretty much slavery
they didn't resist
yeah definitely well some people did but
still what i mean is most people didn't
resist
the government if the government came
out was like everybody dropped your
knees people would go like okay
because they don't want to go to jail
right in the beginning of vietnam
they were it was very pro-war people
were into it i guess i i've heard um
especially like in war
one world two like there was a lot of um
you know you're not a man if you don't
go to war and that kind of thing yeah a
lot of pressure yeah
joel hart says to quote tom mcdonald you
worry about leaving a better planet for
our kids
how about leaving better kids for our
planet oh
mike drought tom mcdonald
kuya chris says hey guys some people are
blaming trump for all the asian hate
because of the anti-china stuff what do
you guys think i think it's an excuse
from people who haven't been dealing
with the actual racial problems in this
country
in fact have been making it worse when
they demonize asians as white adjacent
or actually more privileged than white
people
or even coming to the point where just
in the past few months they were like
asians are white yeah then all this
stuff happens like oh don't look at me
dude these people went on racist tirades
for years about asian people
so i don't blame trump for that alex b
says skateboarding's such an amazing
amazing and uh skilled
skill teaching experience the
camaraderie relationships and
experiences are character building
i think so but i think skateboarding has
become too mainstream
in that it's it it
yeah it's in the olympics it's an
olympic sport so now you've been seeing
this over the past decade where it's
like
kids who have coaches and trainers and
it's like
we want to see 50 kick flips today and
it's just so different from what
skateboarding establishment yeah so it's
getting to a point where there's there's
there's still that effort of
skateboarding culture but
i'd be willing to bet with the emergence
of park skating is when we really
started to see
skateboard culture kind of
go bad in a sense or lose its soul
there are a lot of people who are like
hey man times change and i'm like oh i
totally get it
like i i have this anecdote about
watching the the the older generation
wear baggy pants
then my generation wore the skin tight
pants and then the younger generation
wore the flooded dickies where they're
like they didn't go down to their ankles
and i'm like and i was like word man do
your thing feel good about yourself
but that was still part there was still
soul in that now it's like cookie cutter
corporate
now it's like you watch some of these
people and it's like oh man this is
going to be boring
it's going to be like you know burning
man yeah where's the edge
yeah it's just it's fine if
skateboarding becomes
a traditional american pastime corporate
endeavor
it used to be if you wanted to skate a
certain way you had to go on the streets
because
we didn't have parks now then parks
exploded and then there's a lot of
people now who are like why skate street
they only skate at a park it's
considered not as like legit to do a
trick at a skate park than if you did it
in the actual streets because you're
like conquering real terrain
but i think we're getting dan like it's
coming to the point now where it's just
gonna be park skating
you know so like the soul the original
which maybe is a good thing
because there's a lot of kids who act a
fool and they'll like fight with cops or
fight with security guards and one
security guard got like
killed because some guy shoved them and
like you know it's a whole whole lot of
bad stuff
but you know it is what it is man you
know we we we don't own everything
forever and sometimes things change got
accepted i suppose
so i'll just keep doing my thing and and
stay real to myself
downey jr says sex wasn't specifically
banned in the uk we were banned from
visiting other houses outside of bubbles
outdoor meetups are allowed now and all
retail opens on the 12th of april
zero restrictions from june 21st a lot
of people no babies
carl schneider says working hard on and
appreciating what you have worked for is
the cure for the disease of communism
people who don't actually earn what they
have are riddled with guilt
vote for government to take care of the
poor to ease their unconscious
golan stop says what do you guys think
of adoption i think it's fantastic
i like it yeah that's a great idea i saw
a video lydia sent me where a chicken
adopted kittens
yes i think that your family is not your
blood relatives necessarily but what
you're familiar with and you choose your
family
even if you feel like you're thrust into
what you're born with you can always
find another
place to be familiar baby kittens you
know cats like to be really warm so they
lay on computers
and so the lady sent me this video where
there's baby kittens and there's a
chicken
and the guy walks over to the chicken
and the chicken stands up and the
kittens are underneath it
because the chicken's all like i got to
keep these babies warm yeah and the cats
are like
we want to the kittens want to be warm
you know those kids are going to grow up
they're going to be like
chicken is my friend i love i love
chicken you know that's right
i love those videos when animals get
along and don't kill each other
all right let's see we got prometheus
prime says
the problem with pro-fam anti-fam is
simply a complex
neo-feminism has swapped the roles of
men and women our country
i disagree with that but he says our
country and people are under
concentrated attack and their target is
the family unit
china is hyper masculinizing and we are
regressive
they didn't swap the roles of men and
women uh neo-feminism
for the most part is erasing
feminine femininity you know what i mean
telling women to work jobs freeze their
eggs and just have kids later
they're not going to mend and be like
men must be in the home they're going
women must be in the workplace women
must be ceos
there is a at advocacy for well men can
be stayed at home dance if they want
yeah
but where's the men must be also running
the home
the the the sentiment is not there not
at all
so it's all pushing heavily into the
masculine this is making me think that
maybe we actually do live in a
patriarchy they just want us to be like
men they don't want men to be like women
i mean a little bit maybe but ugh that
makes me mad
ryan mcdougall says i'm a 36 year old
single dad of an 11 year old girl
having a kid is something you don't know
how great it is until you raise your own
jack the text says it's not about the
energy you have now tim it's about the
it's about having energy 10 to 15 years
from now when you're pushing 50-ish and
your kid wants and needs you there
dude i got energy for days
the energizer bunny either either i'm a
candle burning twice as bright by the
time i'm 50 i'll be like
or i'm going to be like you know there's
something to um this is really out there
but like uh internet video and people
thinking about you
when they're watched because right now
like people are watching tim's videos
thousands and thousands of people are
perceiving tim and thinking about tim
and listening
so that energy is like bouncing off our
stratosphere into his body
and yeah interesting possibly so
all right troy bruce i was going to add
something i don't know about you guys
family situations
but another benefit to having kids young
that i didn't
really think about is having your
parents there to help you
yes good point um that his grandparents
my son's grandparents have been there to
like babysit and stuff like that
and because i wouldn't trust a stranger
with my child it was really helpful
for them to be around so just something
to think about that's a great point
yeah troy bruce says ninth u.s circuit
court of appeals in san francisco upheld
a hawaii law
that bans residents from openly carrying
firearms without a license that is
issued only to those who can show
they need the weapon to protect life or
property the line in the sand has been
crossed
it may go to the supreme court i believe
it will but whether or not supreme court
takes another another issue
and if they do the floodgates may be
opened and constitutional carry may
may go uh nationwide that would be
amazing could you imagine if overnight
it was just like no state can ban
someone from walking around with a gun
keeping bear arms shall not be infringed
that'd be incredible beautiful
uh in in many places particularly like
maryland you have to prove you need the
gun
yeah and you can't yeah you you can't
it's very
very hard yeah you have so typically
they say if you transport large sums of
money
yeah or if you have like an active
threat against you they know about
but for the most part they'll just deny
you and it takes like what six months or
some ridiculous amount of time
yeah you have to have receipts that
someone's trying to well
to be fair the constitution does say the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
only in the instance where the
individual has a good reason for having
the gun and can prove it to the
government
otherwise i didn't read that it's
actually really small
you know and people just overlook the
text but it's there
it's in there i love the people who are
like but the well-regulated militia part
i don't care shut up
you're wrong uh gray gianico
says just a daily reminder that trevor
still sucks yeah
does he whoa yeah it's true i forgot
definitely yeah yeah you were taught me
earlier that trevor sucks
yeah i hate that guy
i don't know who trevor is
trevor if you're out there you got a
super chat now so that we you know yeah
we got to set the record straight let's
go
all right let's see chad aldridge says i
know you've talked about it being too
hard to book some people
some more bookable names you might
consider ian hutchison nuclear engineer
fusion discussion
bob murphy anarchist economist yes he's
cool
bob murphy yeah cool write this down
it comes highly recommended by julie
very cool oh yeah
uh danine s says maybe maybe i missed
something but when talking about
depression people need to distinguish
between situational depression and
clinical depression
clinical depression isn't just uh
doesn't just look like crying and
hopelessness
it can be anxiety attacks or numbness it
could also be someone
saying they don't feel like going out
and they're bored and tired
and they're you know their legs are sore
yeah and a lot of people don't realize
that
sam goode says hey bro i'm a veteran who
was who has deployed i'm also
pseudo liberal slash conservative i see
amazing from
amazing from both sides of the voters on
the spectrum right or left it'll flake
both to turn around the world it'll take
both
heck yeah well yep
steph mlb says culture's big if one
wants kids
easy to date but men of value are hard
to find
with two days political politics and
weak men
she says i'm latina in med school but
also 27 given the choice i give up med
for kids
here is taboo why many can be doctors
but only i am able to carry on my
lineage man that's a good point
jeffrey n fraser says great show tim i
would like to see you do a segment on
timcast.com
with pierogi from scammer payback about
the scams that are happening and what
can be done to stop them
oh yeah for sure that'd be cool all
right see we'll do a couple more super
chats here just a couple more two more
sony james says just goes to show you
anyone who might protest the state gets
shot
our government is equal opportunity
shooters i'm already seeing the woke
crowd run defense for this killing
well sometimes i can't read that part
but i get your point
spicy yup sometimes a little too spicy
for youtube huh
uh i just want to say to everybody who
gave a shout out to ian for his birthday
thank you for your super chat and happy
birthday
yes thank you and to the people saying
tom mcdonald is a guest we absolutely
would love to but
tom's a very busy guy so let's see two
no spam says julie i have a cool story
wrt julie with respect to julie is that
what that means with regard to yeah
oh with her cartoon about two years ago
i bought a signed copy of her book
nobody knows how to make a pizza was
quite amazed that she took time to write
a note
go girl oh how very nice of you i could
do autographed copies too
oh i love it yes all right we'll do one
more
bitcoin honda says just had my first son
congratulations
he is two months old and i can't believe
how much my life has changed in just
two months very amazing congratulations
we're gonna do one more aura karina says
as a single father of a little girl in
elementary school
i find it weird that i'm the youngest
father around and i'm in my 30s
crazy times my friends well hey to
everybody who
hung out this friday night thank you so
much make sure you smash that like
button before you go
subscribe hit that notification bell i
wonder if we're going to break 1 million
subscribers
because we're very very close maybe not
i don't know hopefully but we're very
close so probably in the next few days
it'll definitely happen and thank you
all so much for everybody who subscribed
and uh you know hopefully we'll be
around on youtube for a lot longer
if you really like the show hit that
share button post the link in other
places that people watch and let them
know why you like it and to give it a
shot
that really helps you can follow me on
all social media platforms at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comcastnews this show is
live monday the friday at 8pm and also
timcast.com guys has a huge
massive library of exclusive bonus
segments and episodes
where we swear a lot really recently i
did a segment with jack murphy where
like i went off we were talking about
whether or not you should like what you
should do in the event of a mugging and
i was very much like
i would rather die in my feet than live
on my knees and if people were armed and
it could defend themselves we wouldn't
have these criminals in the first place
so
it gets a little spicy and a lot of
people were commenting so you might like
it go to
teamcast.com subscribe become a member
check it out and uh julie do you want to
mention anything before we go
uh sure you can follow me on twitter
julie burowski
youtube julie browsi i don't know just
google my name you'll find something
you have some books i do i have nobody
knows how to make a pizza and i also
have a new book
a peaceful porcupine and these are
libertarian-ish or how would you
describe it i don't like to say they're
libertarian-ish because it sounds kind
of cringe like i'm trying to
force political audiology on kids i say
they're educational and they teach kids
about morality especially peaceful
porcupine it talks about you know don't
hurt
other people which is important whether
you're libertarian or not because it'll
jam quills into you and you'll deserve
it
the armed porcupine peaceful but will
defend himself
yes that's exactly the point there you
go i think um jordan peterson talked a
lot about the meek
from the bible the me shall inherit the
earth and meek wasn't like weak it was
the person with the big sword that chose
not to use it
oh indeed i love it one of the
porcupines porcupines yeah or you know
the
the good uh the millions of american gun
owners who don't commit crimes with
their weapons
and then the government comes in the
news yeah we want to take your gun away
from you because some crazy guy did
something
no man well hello everyone thank you hey
thanks again for the birthday wishes of
you guys this is really really fun um
ian crossland you follow me in
crossland.net get all my socials from
there
and i'm happy to see you guys again next
week very cool and again
ian happy birthday i know this birthday
was a little bit of a downer for you i
apologize that russia decided to do this
with chris
today i don't blame you lydia what a
what a cop out what a what a jerk
anyway i'm sour patch lids on twitter
and mines and real sour bachelors on gab
and instagram you guys can follow me
there
and before we go i will read the last
super chat
from the philosopher taxation is theft
julie is awesome thanks for having her
on
thank you thank you all so much to
everybody for hanging out we will be
back
monday and we'll see you all then bye
guys
you